Welcome to a very special weekend edition,
a late night weekend edition.
If you're on the east coast,
it's 1130.
If you're in Hawaii right now,
you're not impressed.
It's only five to five 24,
so 1124 on the east coast.
Um,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast,
this episode is brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com if you go to o,
n n I t use the code named Brogan,
you will save 10% off
any and all supplements.
We're going to keep it
simple cause that's the case.
You may kiss her son.
Oh,
that guy,
we met him this weekend.
The dude who,
uh,
is in the on it,
a power commercial,
the power lifter.
Very,
very cool dude with his
also very cool girlfriend.
And it was hilarious because they were
so happy that we should all over the part
of the commercial where he
hangs out with the girls.
She was so mad about that because
at the end of the commercial,
the,
this is a,
a,
a commercial for a testosterone
supplement called t plus.
And what t plus does is it naturally
stimulates your body to produce more
testosterone than this.
A commercial with this power lifter dude.
Well,
in the beginning of it,
it's just him lifting weights.
All of it makes sense.
You know?
But then the end of it,
it was him with two girls at a
bar and it was like being Mr Sexy.
We need to get a copy of it,
cause I need to see it and took
that shit off the Internet so fast.
And you already said,
I guess I said in one
of the podcasts I said,
I don't want to be like this
guy or like look like this guy.
So he comes up to me,
he goes,
I don't want to look like you,
man.
I'm going to wait.
What?
Wait,
where are you?
And I'm like,
Oh,
you're kissing muscle tote was stop.
You're not telling the truth at all.
You know,
fuck.
You distort reality.
He came up to you and
told you the whole thing.
You didn't,
you knew who he was.
Exactly.
Yeah.
But he said,
and he tweeted it to you,
well fuck you man.
I don't want to be like,
I had no idea who that was.
Okay.
I just thought it was a hater.
I probably blocked him.
I was like,
what?
I don't want to be like you either.
What the fuck that mean?
Whatever.
But he was super nice and I
accidentally put a sticker in this
girlfriend's hair.
Yeah,
Brian was,
he thought it was being cute but putting
desk wants stickers on the pack of
people's back when I was taking photos,
douchebag,
silly bitch.
Anyway,
I'm on a Dotcom o n I t code named
rogue and save yourself some money,
10% off any and all supplements.
Uh,
when,
when is your shows you got a
show in San Diego coming up?
Yeah,
we have one San Diego March 14th.
We have Billy Bono,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
Jason Tebow and uh,
another person that we're working
on that's a pretty big and uh,
tickets are on sale right now.
And also I'm going to uh,
Toronto in July,
but I won't even bother since July.
Yeah,
it's too far away.
All right,
Dr. Steven Greer is here.
We are going to get to the
bottom of a lot of crazy shit.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is one of the most requested
guests ever on the podcast choosing,
choosing music.
Brian,
let's get this thing started officially.
Well,
good experience
[inaudible]
our guests today for folks
who are tuning into this,
um,
ironically a on Sirius satellite radio,
they don't hear the commercial part
of it.
A Dr. Steven Greer,
if you don't know who Dr. Greer is,
there's a thing that a lot of
people are aware of that came out.
This was at 20 2011.
The disclosure project,
was it 2001 2000 was,
did I say 11?
I met one.
I meant right around September 11th.
Right?
That's where the 11 came from my head.
Um,
2001,
uh,
it was a huge,
in the Internet,
a huge point of controversy and a,
a topic of conversation.
It was you,
uh,
on stage introducing
this disclosure project,
explaining how much information
you had access to about,
uh,
alien spacecrafts visiting earth and
how many distinguished high ranking
military people.
And that was where it got shocking.
Uh,
agreed with you.
That was where it got shocking because
that was the first time we'd ever seen
like high ranking military officers,
one after another,
testify that they had personal encounters
with things that are not of this
world.
People who would know the difference
between black ops technology,
the,
the current,
uh,
military defense projects that might be
secret and people that would know also
who to talk to about these things if
they did think it was a black ops,
but they knew they,
and it was,
in my opinion,
that video is probably one of the most
important videos ever when it comes to
extra terrestrial life or the idea of
extraterrestrial life visiting earth.
Because the conversations that I've ever
had that I've always had with rational
people,
um,
especially rational people who are not
obsessed by aliens like I've been my
whole life,
but rational people who just,
you know,
oh,
I don't know.
I don't know if it's real or not,
but you know,
where,
where's the evidence?
I'm sure there's alien life out there.
Has it visited us?
Oh,
I don't,
I probably not.
Right.
When you see that video and you see
those high ranking military guys,
one after another,
give these very,
not just believable,
but they're kind of,
they're,
they're spooky.
These are spooky stories because
the way they're talking about him,
you could see in their face the
emotions as they're recounting the,
just the sheer,
to use a word alien,
this of their experience,
right?
We had never really seen
anything like that before.
It had always been,
well,
I guess they probably could be out there,
but who knows.
When I watched that video,
it was a real,
uh,
it was a real shift because it was one
of the first things that I ever saw that
made me really stop and think.
There's a part of everybody
that doesn't want to get duped.
And when it comes to a subject,
especially an important subject like Ufos,
there's a part of
everybody who goes there.
You want to call bullshit right away
because you don't want to be the last guy
to call bullshit.
You don't want to be the guy who believes,
believes,
and it turns into bullshit.
Ah,
you dummy,
you believed that you were the first guy.
I believe in it man.
You want to be the first
guy to call bullshit.
It's always a way cooler position.
And um,
if,
if there was alien life,
if there was an life that
had visited the earth,
excuse me,
what,
what evidence would they leave behind?
What,
what would you know in
your day to day existence?
How much of it would you know?
Almost nothing
like when it's getting hoovered up by
a very well organized and well funded
intelligence.
The project blue book,
which was run by Jay,
Dr Jay Allen Heineken,
right?
That was a cover story project.
Blue Book was really a little office where
they were putting things in there and
making it sound like they
were really investigating.
Meanwhile,
there was a uh,
unacknowledged project,
what we call it black project,
but the proper name is an
unacknowledged special access project.
Are you SAP and the use saps running
this had been around since the 40
[inaudible] very well funded
working on these issues,
working on the technology,
studying how these things are going
from one star system to another.
And that's the sort of thing that,
that we've been drilling
down on for about 22 years.
So the project Blue Book
that was run by Dr Heinik,
is that,
what's his name,
it Dr J.
Dot.
Allen Hynek right.
He was an air force guy,
a astronomer that the air
force engaged to do that.
Later he came out and admitted
that that was all just sort of a,
a dog and pony show.
And he also became a huge UFO believer,
which is really fascinating because most
of the stories that they investigated
in project blue book,
he sorted debunked.
Correct.
In fact,
instead of being open
about the possibilities,
they always steered towards debunking
first.
Right.
And actually the big problem became when
he put his foot in his mouth when a,
in Gerald Ford's a home
district in Michigan,
there was a whole,
uh,
dozens of people who saw an
extraterrestrial vehicle,
um,
that was some maneuvering,
at close range.
And he went up and investigate it and
made some reference to it being swamp gas.
And,
uh,
Gerald Ford went ballistic because
his constituents went ballistic.
And Gerald Ford actually had an inquiry
into it while he was a member of the
House of Representatives
course later as president,
he never dealt with this issue because
basically the presidential intelligence
doesn't have access to those projects.
When you say that,
uh,
he said it was swamp gas that Jay
on Hynix said it was swamp cast.
So you were saying that Ford objected
because he knew it was an extraterrestrial
vehicle.
He,
he knew that his,
some of his constituents who were very
credible knew it was something real.
What was his position then?
What was he,
he was actually a believed
it was real as the,
no,
I mean,
uh,
in government,
what is prepared
precedent?
Yeah,
it was,
he was,
he was in the House of
Representatives in the congress.
He was a congressman before he was
a vice president and then president.
And so he was upset that they were
saying that it wasn't a real vehicle.
So he clamped down on it.
Yeah.
And actually hold,
held a hearing where a lot of people
came and gave evidence and information,
but it didn't go anywhere
because it's Washington.
Nothing ever goes anywhere in Washington.
And,
um,
so you know,
I started as founder of disclosure
project.org and now serious disclosure.
Dot.
Calm.
We began investigating this in,
in uh,
1990 and you know,
I'm a trauma doctor,
emergency doctor who was running a
very busy er and raising four kids.
And I got involved with this because,
um,
I knew about it since childhood.
And you know,
my,
uh,
I have family,
my,
my mom's brother,
uncle was a engineer that worked on the
lunar module and I had an interest in
this and so I was a little child.
Um,
so the thing that put knew
learning strong on the,
on the moon,
my family had a hand in that.
So I think that what most people don't
realize is that inside the intelligence
community,
the aerospace community,
um,
there are a lot of people who are
very knowledgeable about this,
but they're not allowed to talk about it.
It's a career ender for most of them.
And that was what we did
for disclosure project,
was to put all those folks together,
identify them.
So I spent about 10 years
identifying who these people were in.
First I had maybe half a dozen of them.
Now we have over 500,
about 550.
Who was the most credible people?
Just so folks listening to this
that haven't watched that video,
who are the most credible people?
Well,
we're going to have some
of them in the film.
Serious.
You know this,
I'm like,
sir,
I us,
I'm serious.
Uh,
is going to,
um,
have a lot of this information at it and
some stuff is going to blow your mind,
including the possibility
of an actual body,
um,
a humanoid body that we're investigating.
And we'll get into this in a moment.
And when you see it,
you're going to go really my God.
But you know,
these witnesses that we have
who are military go from
the head of investigations
for the FAA,
John Callahan to people
like Gordon Cooper,
who was one of the early
Mercury astronauts who,
uh,
his crew actually filmed
one of these extra tests,
will vehicles landing on a dry
lake bed out here near Edwards.
And he looked at the film and
send it on a Pentagon plane.
And now the backstory to this,
now this is the go give,
giving you an idea of how labyrinthine
and screwed up Washington's become and
what Eisenhower said,
what he said,
but where are the military industrial
complex because it's going to get out of
control and be a threat to our democracy.
Gordon Cooper,
you know,
very heroic early astronauts had detailed
information what we call actionable
intelligence on that event,
this landing of a vehicle in
broad daylight near Edwards
air force base in 1956.
Now when Clinton was president,
Gordon Cooper asked,
uh,
was asked by the Secretary of Defense,
William Cohen about this issue.
And he says,
yes,
I absolutely will verify this and I'll
give you the information when and where
and how it happened.
So the secretary of Defense of the
United States of America had this
information,
made an inquiry through channels
and came up with a dry hole.
Basically this stuff,
it's all been put into a
parallel universe that,
that senior people in our
government have for the most part,
no access to.
Now,
I would not
have believed that if I hadn't been the
guy who was brought to Washington during
the Clinton years to do the
briefing for the CIA director.
And I was asked to go up there,
uh,
as a service.
And I did it,
left my er and I put together a whole
lot of these early witnesses' testimony,
photographs,
some really amazing government
documents that we acquired,
some through channels I
don't want to talk about.
And I put this briefing together.
And so I go up there and
here's the city CIA director,
um,
uh,
our James Woolsey.
And um,
his wife was there,
who was at the time,
the chief operating officer of
the National Academy of Sciences.
And when I was first invited to go
up there and brief the CIA director,
I was told,
they want you to come up here because
President Clinton and he have inquired
about this subject and
they're being denied access.
Now I have a letter proving this.
President Clinton has been denied access.
So they want you a doctor in who had a
family connection to these programs and,
and also to information
they know about you.
Well,
let me finish this other
thread and I'll get to that.
Um,
because that's they're
blowing your mind even more.
But what happened is that,
um,
I,
I really thought this was crap.
I mean,
because when his handler,
the CIA director,
his handler who contacted me said,
look,
uh,
they need you to come up here
because they can't find out anything.
But they know stuff's going on.
I felt they just wanted to pick,
my brain is sort of spooks,
you know,
how spooks will spies.
We'll try to just get information.
I went up there and the CIA director was
honestly completely in the dark and I
was mortified.
And towards the end of this almost three
hour briefing that I did for the CIA
director,
um,
my wife was with me and I
gave him this white paper,
this position paper that,
a summary of action that the president
needed to take and he needed to take.
Um,
and he,
he,
my hands were shaking cause hang on,
I'm like this 35 year old guy briefing
the sitting CIO director was very
intimidating frankly.
Um,
and you know,
at the end of it I said,
you know,
we really need you to help disclose this
information because the people need to
know,
but also the technologies that we've
studied and have mastered for 50 years
could get us all full hill.
We could fix this environment,
we could fix the world's,
uh,
poverty problems and the geopolitical
problems in the Middle East.
And he looked at me,
he says,
how do we disclose that
which we have no access to?
And I just thought,
I thought I'd pass out.
I said,
what do you mean you have new way?
And this was from his mouth to my ears.
And so I learned the hard way,
the very,
very hard way that when you're
dealing with things that are,
some people say above top secret,
but the proper name is an
unacknowledged special access project.
And we have about a hundred to $200
billion a year and our treasury going into
these rogue operations.
And it's a,
it's a criminal.
It's outrageous,
uh,
that,
you know,
just because you're the CIA director,
just because you're secretary of defense
or on the Senate intelligence committee
means nothing.
Um,
and even the president.
so the reason he,
those folks invited me
to come up there is that,
um,
the year before I had taken a team
of people out on a beach using some
experimental protocols to contact these
vehicles and the occupants and four of
these UFOs pop into the sky.
Just boom,
boom,
which we have on videotape,
not great videotape cause we
didn't have good cameras back then.
And uh,
there were a couple of air force officers
and pilots there and this went up
through the chain of command.
Few months later,
the former head of army intelligence
invites me to a meeting and then some
national security agency people
do and one thing leads to another.
And I'm being invited to brief the
city of CIA director so that you know,
that you contacted these spaceships.
Well this gets into a discussion when,
you know,
that's complex.
Uh,
but yes,
and you can do that at any time.
Well mad at anytime,
but I think that under
the right you can do that.
There are protocols and we developed
something called the close encounters or
the fifth kind initiative,
which is when you use a set of very,
they're very controversial protocols,
um,
that deal with nonlocality the fact
that the universe has various dimensions
that you can move through to go
from one star system to another.
But those dimensions that are at higher
resonant fields than say linear space
time,
uh,
or electromagnetism also interface
with what I call coherent thought.
So the Moody Blues were
right when they said,
I'm thinking is the best way to travel.
Um,
and there's a component to where,
you know,
I'm pregnant,
lose half your listeners,
right?
I've got,
all right,
well pay all you freaks,
listen up and listen apart.
Uh,
you can develop technologies and we have
these in classified projects now where
you can have a,
what's called a switch that will
interface with very intent thought.
So it's beyond,
forget your iPhone now,
if you're traveling from
one star system to another,
that's what you're going to be using.
You're going to be using technologies
that are phasing at multiples of the speed
of light.
And those dimensions also intersect at
a certain point with coherent thought,
just like lightest,
coherent a laser is coherent light.
And so this gets into the whole question
of how over the history of humanity
have there been so many
reports of contact.
And there are,
I mean going all the way back to
the [inaudible] and the Betas to uh,
accounts that,
you know,
there's a wonderful painting and um,
the Middle Ages of,
of this exactly.
It looks like a modern
Ufo over the shoulder of,
of Mary holding Jesus.
And a picture that's been
from the 14 hundreds.
I've actually seen the original of this.
So I think the question becomes,
you know,
we probably have always had
extraterrestrial civilizations
observing our little
planet.
Um,
the question is what happened in the last
50 to a hundred years that really got
their attention.
And I'm quite convinced it was when we
started detonating thermonuclear weapons.
But my,
one of the projects we're involved
with is disclosure project.
And another one is sort of a
citizen's diplomacy efforts.
Saying,
look,
since our government is dead in the water
on this in terms of the secretary of
state and folks like that,
um,
and I know I went up to
the UN and met with um,
back when boots was boots with Scalia,
was UN secretary general and brief
these guys and hit her lay layer.
Golly though the wife,
the secretary general and I
talked about this in depth and he,
she said they're not going to let
us deal with something like this.
So I started a citizens diplomacy effort
back in 1990 but this is actually,
and this is the part that I
get ridiculed the most for,
but it's the reason why the intelligence
community took it most seriously.
It's that they knew that we had discovered
the Rosette of stone of contact and
they were very concerned.
Now concern from the covert end,
from the end of a lot of
these Washington operatives,
they were just fascinated.
They didn't understand it because
it was sort of pass there,
their scientific understanding,
but they should.
Very interesting,
this is something,
I hate it or interrupt you.
No,
please come in and we can't
really just gloss over,
um,
the,
the idea that coherent thought as you say,
intersects with these,
uh,
other levels,
these other dimensions that
we can't normally access.
Correct.
Um,
how did you find out about this and how
did you develop the ability on a hot
seat early man?
Well,
I need to be need.
You have to,
when you say that you can do that,
I mean somehow or another you have
to without getting anybody killed.
You have to explain.
How'd you figure that out?
I figured it out when
I was a teenager and,
uh,
through a series of experiences I had,
and you know,
I was,
I was talking to Thomas Jane who's an
actor here in town about this and I had a
near death experience when I was 17.
It was very sick and,
um,
uh,
hand experienced.
That took me into some awareness about
the nature of consciousness and the
nonlocality of mind and the fact that
the mind is actually a singularity,
that there's really only one mind
and it's just shining through various
individuals appearing as many.
And this experience,
although it sounds very spiritual
and religious was very palpable.
And I was raised a very devout atheist,
so we didn't believe in anything.
And so when I realized that this was real,
I began to study meditation.
And through that began to have some
experiences where I realize this could
happen.
And I had a contact experience.
I was 18,
it was a few months later in the
fall of 1973 and I was doing this,
I was meditating and then I was doing
what's now called Srv scientific remove
viewing where you use
consciousness to see remote places.
And of course,
army intelligence and the CIA have
experiment with this for years.
Um,
which you may or may not know about.
We can get into that.
But,
um,
I know all those guys.
I know all this RV people and,
but I was as a kid,
you know,
and I just turned 18.
I was doing this and suddenly I had
this experience where I thought,
well,
what if I tried to go into that state of
one mind that I experienced when I was
a kid,
uh,
six,
six months earlier when I had
this near death experience.
So I did.
And then I had an experience where I
remote viewed and salt eat space and um,
could see that there was an eet spacecraft
out there and I made contact and it
appeared and it literally materialized,
uh,
right near the mountain where I was
18.
No drugs?
No,
no.
I've never done any drawer.
Never done engines.
No.
Psychedelics.
Nothing ever.
Wow.
No.
Are you aware,
aware of dimethyltryptamine?
Do you know what can I do?
You know,
it's a,
supposedly your brain produces it when
you're in periods of extreme stress or
near death experiences.
And it's,
uh,
also the same chemical that's in Iowasca,
which has been used by
indigenous tribes too.
Right now.
This was just,
this was a very natural
sort of thing that happened.
Yeah.
But,
but,
but what I'm saying is that these people
that are having these experiences that
are having a lot of people that are
having alien contact experiences,
they are all having them
in the middle of the night,
like most of them or having them at night.
And I'm not discounting this in any way.
In fact,
I maybe possibly enhancing the,
uh,
the possibility of people
understanding this or the,
the vehicle.
Um,
the,
the mind produces this dimethyltryptamine
during rem sleep and uh,
it's believed it.
So it's still a very sketchy thing.
We know that the body produces it.
We know we,
they believe the pineal gland,
which is literally your third eye and
reptiles it as a retina and the cornea in
Atlanta,
they believe that's what the
evidence on an apparently,
it's like really kind of,
it's hard to figure out exactly.
But they know the body has it.
They know it's produced by the
liver and the lungs for sure.
And this chemical,
when you get it and you give it to
people that have had UFO abduction
experiences,
it gives them the exact same experience.
Um,
it,
it brings them into
contact with other beings.
The idea that this is just a
hallucination because you are,
your body has some,
uh,
in,
in dodginess chemical in it and its spikes
and stimulates the visual cortex and
what have you and you have this,
that is what everyone has always assumed.
Uh,
whenever you talk about anything
hallucinatory or Psychedelic,
but what they're not,
what a lot of people haven't taken into
consideration is that you're basically a
conglomeration of chemicals,
your neurotransmitters,
dopamine,
Serotonin,
and there's a million different chemicals
which w as their levels vary up and
down,
it drastically changes your reality,
your happiness level,
your appreciation,
love,
oxytocin,
all of these things proven
100% change your reality.
You change the physical meet
vehicle reality that you have.
And I think for whatever reason,
when we think of something in the mind,
when we think of the mind,
like you're,
you're saying that coherent thought
can contact other entities from other
people.
Like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
You know,
that's like the initial
immediate reaction,
right?
Misunder miss,
educate about the nature of it.
Well of consciousness,
conscious for you.
I've always tried to get people
to try to understand how bizarre.
Just just imagination is.
And I don't mean imagination by you're
imagining things that aren't there,
that's not real.
You're,
you're playing games with your mind.
What I mean by imagination is everything,
including the language that
we're speaking with right now,
the vehicle in which this language is
getting delivered through the Internet.
All of this came from the imagination.
Everything.
This table came from.
The imagination is the arm
that holds this microphone.
Someone thought this shit up and then
all of a sudden it manifested itself in a
physical form when they
actively created it.
That seems so normal to us.
It seems so normal,
but we're the only fucking animal in
the world we know that can do that.
Well,
the,
and it goes beyond that because,
you know,
Doctor John at Princeton University
had the Princeton engineering anomalies
research lab and I knew Dr John and,
um,
they had proven that you could set up a
random number generator machine and put
your thought towards it and begin to move,
whether it's spitting out zeros or ones.
And that there is in fact,
uh,
been proven scientifically that the
mind is actually operating non-locally
meaning that it's not limited to
the space and time in a linear way.
And these studies that have been done
by Dean Raden and Dr John and many other
scientists,
um,
with very good credentials.
I mean,
Doctor John was a engineer and,
uh,
at Princeton,
what they found is that in fact the
mind itself is what urban Trojans
Schrodinger said.
And Urban Schroders or of course was the
father of four a particle wave theory
and quantum mechanics.
And I think it was in 1910 or so.
He said the total number of mines
in the universe is one that is,
it's a singularity.
And so that understanding is,
uh,
I mean,
I know it sounds sort of 'em out there,
but,
no,
I mean it,
it actually sounds very vedic,
um,
in the sense of,
of,
of the,
of Buddhist or of Vedanta.
But it'd be too,
I mean,
I guess to maybe Sarah Palin,
but,
um,
I say that,
I'm sorry,
I apologize.
Um,
but the reason I'm late
is the world isn't flat.
Um,
and there's a whole area of physics and
science that has been drilled down on
for years that establish
all these things is true.
It isn't talked about because I'm the
high priests of religion and the high
priests of science are all opposed
to this information coming out.
So the idea though,
part of the secrecy around this whole
Ufo issue isn't just the physical energy
and propulsion systems.
It's the paradigm.
Because if you be,
if you asked the question,
I'm back.
Yeah.
Going back to this dinner with
the CIA director and his wife,
very smart lady,
and she turns in,
we're sitting across
the table having dinner.
I mean,
that was the cover story was
it was a dinner and she says,
how are they communicating
across the vastness of space?
And of course I had the,
you know,
I didn't know whether to tell her
something that sounded scientific,
so I maintain my credibility or to tell
her the truth and risk losing all my
credibility.
But I decided then in the early days
of this project that if someone smart
enough to ask the question,
I'm going to answer it honestly,
even though it's going to blow their mind.
And so I looked at her and her husband,
the CIA director sitting next to it,
right?
It didn't really understand
where she was going.
And I said,
look,
take her Milky Way.
It's a hundred thousand
light years across.
All right?
So that in a hundred thousand
light years as a distance,
that's how far you would go at 186,000
miles a second for a hundred thousand
years going at that speed.
Then that's just our own galaxy.
Now you take 1% of that,
say a thousand light years at the speed
of your cell phone or radio wave or TV
waiver.
This system we're using right here for
someone from a star system 1% of the way
through our galaxy for them to say,
hello,
how are you?
And for a spacecraft that's
at another star system,
a thousand light years away,
see here earth to say fine,
how are you doing?
That just took how long?
4,000 years.
2000 years.
1001 way in 1000 and other.
So at the time since the birth of Christ,
so the speed of light is too damn slow.
And so when you,
when you begin to go through what
I call the crossing point of light,
it's like the sound
barrier was a big deal.
The biggest deal is the light barrier.
And when you go past the light barrier,
you're going to cross into these and
kind of multifaceted resonant dimensions,
part of which hook into the
singularity of mind and thought.
And actually this film
that we're working on,
which is the largest crowd
funded documentary in history,
to my knowledge,
a serious,
and you can find out about it,
serious disclosure.com it's
been crowdfunded by the public.
It's all been funded by people out there,
thousands of people.
Um,
we're gonna do a,
um,
oh,
we're going to do a,
um,
premiere here in La on April
22nd if you want to come.
But I would love to,
okay,
come.
We can't send things
to the speed of light.
Right.
And even,
even that,
even saying that beyond
the speed of light,
but they can't do that,
right?
I mean there's,
you can't send information in,
in a form of light yet,
can you
not?
Well,
no,
but I'm well,
fiber optics and things of this sort.
But does that move at the speed of light?
Pretty much.
Yeah,
but,
but what I'm saying is that if
you go beyond the speed of light,
right,
it's a whole new physics of course.
Okay.
So that's what if,
if these craft are here and now we have,
I have over 4,000 cases
where they've landed.
And we have evidence.
I have 3,500 pilot cases.
We have over 500 whistle blowers,
top secret military corporate people.
And I have 110 of them
on digital video tape,
although nobody wants to see it.
But I have it.
So the question is,
if they're here,
how the hell they get here,
or they're not using an Exxon jet a fuel
and they're not using a solid rocket
booster and the not using an
eye on drive or anything linear.
So you have to begin
to have this question.
So when the CIA director's
wife asked me this,
I told her about that
they had technologies that
interface with thought and
consciousness.
And that sounded,
it's Biz may sound as
bizarre to people now,
but if you took your cell phone
and show Thomas Jefferson,
your smartphone,
um,
they would think it was magic.
If you went to Salem,
Massachusetts couple hundred years ago,
you'd be burned at the stake as a witch.
So the point is,
is that people have to have some humility
about the fact that humans are one
half of one step out of the jungle.
Technologically.
And we're only a hundred or so years
into anything resembling real technology.
So when we're dealing with civilizations
that are attended the six to 10 to the
seventh 100,000 to a
million years ahead of us,
we have to have some humility
about what that might look like.
And so when I explained this
to the wife to say I director,
she just looked at me and said,
I thought it had to be
something like that.
I mean,
people are ready to
actually understand this.
Not everyone has to be retarded on this.
And I tell folks that it's,
what's a shame in my mind is that our
civilization has been exploring these sort
of what they called border land
sciences for a hundred years.
And it's all been kept very
secret or debunked or ridiculed.
And it's actually holding us back
not only socially and spiritually,
but environmentally
and in every other way.
Because this nexus of where you have
these advanced trans dimensional physics
come together.
That's how you're propelling through
one point in space to another across
galaxies.
It's also how we're going to be able
to run this planet's energy grid.
Uh,
without a grid where every home business
and car can pull energy out of the
fabric of space time through
this kind of physics.
And so there's this nexus
where electromagnetism and
trans dimensional physics
comes together and then you cross it a
little deeper and that's where you get
into the science of consciousness.
And this becomes a very,
very complex issue for most
people because it's new to them.
But once you understand the
fundamental science behind it,
it's really very simple.
What we need to understand is that no
one 200 years ago even thought of a
camera,
right?
200 years ago,
when you want to picture something,
you had to draw it and there was,
you know,
the idea of a camera was,
so the idea of a movie,
the idea of sending a video
on your phone to your friend,
you could take a video of you here right
now and send it to a friend and they
would get it almost instantly.
That's just a tiny blip in,
in human history,
a 200 year blip in human history from
riding horses to sending video through the
Internet.
Or a hundred years.
Yeah.
And the people that existed back
then would have never seen a calming.
And if technology,
and we know it does,
accelerates exponentially what we're
dealing with a thousand years from now,
10,000 years from now,
it's completely unrecognizable.
We live in an area where our
solar system is kind of scary.
There's a lot of rocks out there and
they fly around and occasionally slamming
the shit and they can,
they can ruin civilization
for a little bit.
But there might be solar
systems out there would,
that doesn't take place.
There could be a civilization that
develops to 3 billion years ago.
I mean,
we really don't know.
We have no idea.
Well,
the earth has had life or 700 million
years and all scientists recognize,
recognize that except people who think
that the world was made 6,000 years ago.
And I have nothing to say to those
folks except to say get over it.
Um,
but uh,
I know I'm just,
I'm an outrageous person.
You are a little outdated.
A little bit,
a little bit outrageous.
Haven't heard anything yet.
Yeah,
I'm ready.
I'm already strapped in,
so,
uh,
but it,
but if you really look at our,
our technological development,
you know,
my grandmother was born in
post reconstruction south
in the late 18 hundreds her
son worked on the lunar module,
put the first man on the moon.
But by the time we landed on the moon
in 1969 we were 15 years into having
classified antigravity propulsion devices.
The biggest mind fuck that I was trying
to drop on people with time is between
the invention of the airplane.
It was less than 50 years.
It's someone used that airplane
to drop a nuclear weapon.
Right.
And see this is,
this is pretty crazy.
It gets into the whole question
I've had a lot of people ask me.
We have a,
if you go to our sites,
serious disclosure.com there's a section
that has all these top secret military
guys on it.
And part of it is that we,
there's a whole grouping of them.
Have a dozen of them or so who were at
strategic air command facilities and
nuclear weapons storage areas and
processing areas and all this stuff.
And every one of them were overflown
by 80 spacecraft back in the forties
fifties sixties because they were very
concerned about what we were doing
because we were going from having
these technologies to weaponizing them.
And our technological development had
gotten ahead of our social and spiritual
development way ahead.
And this,
this is an existential threat,
but you know,
as an emergency doctor,
I used to have,
you know,
crazy people come into the er
and I'd have to commit them.
And you know,
it's dangerous to yourself or others.
And,
and what I've found is that if you just
take a step back and look at humanity
through the eyes of
extraterrestrial civilizations,
we've become dangerous to ourselves,
but we're also dangerous to others.
And moreover we become a existential
threat to the biosphere of the earth where
we're killing the oceans,
the atmosphere and everything else.
All this is unnecessary.
So the question is,
the misanthropic sociopaths that are
running the planet into the ground are
going to have to be stood down by
the people getting behind disclosure,
getting behind the technologies
and basically saying,
we're not,
we're fed up and we're not going
to put up with this anymore.
It's like the movie network.
Um,
and we're mad as hell and I think people,
and it isn't about doing anything violent,
it's
about saying we need to just move forward
because Washington isn't going to do
it.
My uncle's company,
Northrop Grumman isn't Lockheed
Martin isn't going to do it.
It's you and me and the other people
out there who get the situation we're in
and wanting to fix it.
One of the things that might have also
got their attention was a operation
starfish prime.
You aware of that from 1962 where they
launched a nuclear bomb in a space,
blew up a nuclear bomb and space.
Well,
actually one of our witnesses,
Colonel Diedricksen,
was with the atomic energy commission,
which became the doe and he was a air
force colonel and his responsibility was
overall the nuclear facilities.
But he knew of a program where we were
going to lob a thermonuclear weapon and
detonate it on the moon and when that,
okay.
And they actually worked on this
and when it went XO atmospheric,
when it left our atmosphere and,
and it was intercepted by an expert
trestle vehicle and basically the
materialized was taken out and he knew
had personal knowledge of this so,
so they can actually tried to do this.
They actually launched it and
it was on its way to the moon.
Um,
so,
um,
you know,
there've been a lot of really creepy,
it's like doctor strange love on steroids,
um,
with some of these guys and you know,
I still work with a lot of folks who are
with the agency and aerospace industry
and there's a term at the naval
research labs and CIA for,
for this whole area of science.
And it's called W s f.
M it stands for,
it's not a radio station by the way.
It stands for weird
science and fricking magic.
And that's what they call it.
And it's grown,
man.
Just never used the word frigging.
Yeah,
I don't,
this is what they call it.
They need to be stopped.
And they have that access to technology
and they're using the word frickin that
you can be trusted them.
Oh,
you can't,
they're,
they're held back.
Actually,
I'll tell you,
a lot of them are really good people
who want to see the secrecy end,
but there's not much they can do
as an individual when you're in a
compartmentalized sort of a system.
Like,
well,
I got a lot of them come forward.
Lord,
you know,
every,
almost all of our top secret
guys had signed security owes.
But here,
here's something I want everyone done.
Listen carefully.
Daniel,
she hand who is accustomed constitutional
attorney who did Pentagon papers and,
and,
and Silkwood case in all this.
He and I ran this by him.
I said,
look,
I've done briefings for,
here's a short list.
The director of Central Intelligence,
the head of the defense
intelligence agency,
members of the Senate
Intelligence Committee,
uh,
senior people who are on the house.
Uh,
various health committees,
government oversight committee,
um,
presidential staff,
uh,
the head of intelligence for
the joint chiefs of Staff,
what's called j two personally,
I took astronaut Edgar Mitchell
to one of those briefings for the,
for the admiral,
Admiral Tom Wilson.
And,
and every one of these people had been
inquiring about this issue and had been
denied access.
One of them who I will not name,
uh,
I learned for my briefing with him.
I had given a document that's
going to be in this film,
serious.
And the document isn't it?
It's on the front of the thing.
That briefing I put together
for President Obama.
And if you go down the list when you
put together a briefing for President
Obama,
yeah.
It,
we asked you to
someone senior involved with his team did.
Um,
and so Jesus Christ,
okay.
Yeah.
Weird.
Must that be to be the president
and then to get in there and go,
okay,
what the fuck is going on with
the emperor has no clothes.
Hey,
call that that doctor,
what's that guy's name?
Virginia.
Dr. Greer,
go get that guy.
Yeah.
So,
no,
but what happened is that,
uh,
when,
when he,
this admiral looked at
this document and it's gonna blow
people's mind when they see this,
uh,
it's a national reconnaissance office
document in our OE does all the top secret
spy satellites and over
their headquarters,
it says we own the night
and the,
Oh yeah,
that's their motto.
We own the night.
It's pretty,
yeah,
it's a pretty spooky.
Yeah.
But so,
you know,
these are the kind of dudes
I work with all the time.
What happened is that the
one of these compartments,
it has a whole district
Bhushan lists,
cosmic ops,
magic ops,
Dadadadada,
Dah,
um,
you know,
uh,
all kinds of insights about 20 of them.
And this is a document
that was not declassified,
that was given to me by a
source that I won't talk about.
And this admiral recognize
one of those compartments.
So he contacted them and on the
other end of the phone they said,
he said,
look,
I'm so and so.
And they said,
yes,
sir,
we know who you are.
And he says,
well,
I want to be read into,
which is military speak for
briefed on this project.
And they said,
sir,
we cannot discuss this project with you.
You don't have a need to know.
He says,
what do you mean I'm the
head of intelligence for
the Joint Chiefs of Staff.
How can I not have a need to know?
And they said,
sir,
we will not discuss this with you.
Blocked him.
So who the fuck knows who's who's
like how many people are there?
The,
have you determined that the,
yeah,
I have,
um,
I know some of the members of,
of the,
of,
there's a committee
and it's transnational.
Um,
it,
it started out much smaller and less
opaque back in the forties when Truman was
around have a name.
It did have the name majestic.
Um,
and that is not a myth.
and so even just 12,
right?
Is that what it was?
Yes.
But,
uh,
the,
the document as of the
nineties that I got,
it's still had magic Maj I see on it.
Um,
and so a lot of these programs,
you know,
they've gone through
multiple generations of,
of evolution.
And now I understand it's a
committee of two or 300 folks,
um,
who are,
you know,
corporate,
very deep kind of shadow
government operations.
And the mistake the public makes is that
they think that just because you're the
president or the CIA director or member
of the Senate intelligence committee,
you're going to have access to those.
And that's because they do not understand
what Rumsfeld said is true on the day
before nine 11.
And there's going to be in the film where
he said there's two point $3 trillion,
basically missing that we can
account for how the Department of
Defense budget over the last few years,
two point 3 trillion,
not billion.
Now we found out,
uh,
and I discovered this
in the early nineties,
that there's somewhere between a
hundred and 200 billion a year,
basically just being stolen,
going into these illegal projects.
And so when she had an,
I looked at this,
this attorney,
I said,
look,
if all these people who have a need
to know in the constitutional chain of
command or being lied to
to see and what have you,
I'm going to declare all those projects,
rogue op,
priori illegal.
Therefore anyone who signed a security,
as for them,
I'm going to unilaterally announced
that they're released from them.
So all of you listening,
if you've been in any of
these projects with Lockheed,
Northrup sic,
the CIA,
you do not have to go by the secrecy
because if they are denying access to the
people who are in the
constitutional chain of command,
which I can prove they
have in a court of law,
those projects are rogue and
therefore those security owes have no
enforceability.
Now,
whether or not you have the courage
to come forward is another question,
but what,
what I was very glad to be able to do
between the early nineties and 2001 with
the disclosure project is to pull together
the people who did have the courage
and they're still coming forward.
When we have people contact me all
the time who are in these projects,
who give us information intelligence,
um,
and it's really a citizen's effort.
I mean I've never been in the
government in my entire life,
but uh,
I think this is what you have an idea
and if the idea to picks up steam and
people see the reason for it.
But the other thing is to do it in a,
in a way where people feel supported.
And that's why we did this in
a way where there were dozens.
It came out at once.
I mean,
I think in the initial batch
of people came forward,
it was about 71
of the things I always want to get into
people's heads when they start talking
about the government or the
people in charge or you know,
those in the know,
the idea that they're
exchanging information is,
is been proven false time and time again.
Not only that,
what's really blown me away
lately is finding out that,
especially in this,
suppose that patriotic time of war,
we have government factions that
don't like other government factions.
It's always been that way.
I was blown away when
Petraeus was outed by the FBI.
I'd be like,
are you fucking crazy?
That is nuts.
You're,
you're talking about the head of the
CIA and the FBI spying on him over in a
fair and you're going to bring
down this beloved national hero,
stupid,
unbelievably stupid,
but also unbelievably revealing about
how partitioned our government truly is
and how difficult it would
be to get access to some
critical information if this
information is in any
way deemed too sensitive
or too controversial or two to whatever
to paradigm shifting for average eyes.
Well,
let's make this very simple.
If you acknowledge that the
UFOS are there and they're real,
um,
and anyone with an Iq over mud,
it's going to ask the question,
then how did they get here?
If you asked that question,
we have the answers for it
and if the public knows that,
then they know we don't need Exxon mobile.
We don't need oil,
gas,
coal,
nuclear power or centralized utility grid.
That's assuming though that most people
believe that the Ufos are real because I
know 50 to 60% do now.
I think they say that.
I think they say,
but I think the most of the time we'll
look for terrestrial explanations.
Most rational people,
well no,
actually what I'm now this,
there was just a poll that came out a
month ago and there's actually 43% of the
public believe that extra terrestrial
life has been on the planet and it's here
now.
51% believed that the earth
is less than 10,000 years old.
Just don't have that yet.
Well there,
well I don't know if it's that high.
I heard it was about a
quarter of the population.
So Gallup poll I think 2010 2010 they
got 51% of the flat Earth Society still
has a lot of members I guess.
But you know,
here,
here's the,
here's the bigger issue is that
if you bring this information out,
uh,
and let's,
let's say that one of the objectives
of what I'm working on now,
let me just clear that up.
46% okay.
Creationist view of
human origins 40 46 well,
but of the creationist view,
not all those people think that world
is 10,000 years old and I think that
number is only about 15 years though.
They're saying 10,000 years.
This is what in this study,
the Gal study,
these very specifically,
46% of Americans believe
the creations for you,
that God created humans in their present
form at a time within the last 10,000
years.
Oh God,
you're gonna make me move to Norway.
Anyway,
that was a good choice to count is
right there and they're bad ass.
Just to throw some salt on your
idea that you want me to look,
I told you that I'm,
I'm,
I'm a huge fan of the UFO experience.
I mean,
I really want it to be real,
but just because 47% of whatever the fuck
think 46% think that the earth is less
than,
or you're writing and,
but the,
the evidence speaks for itself
and I told someone once,
but does it,
what percentage?
Okay,
let's,
let's just be honest.
Or,
or rather,
let's open this.
What percentage of Ufo sightings are real,
what,
how,
what percentage are totally made up
and what percentage are a confusion.
But that's not the metric we're using.
We're going by,
uh,
government release documents were going
by people who are insiders who have
actually handled extra trust.
Right?
So when you're talking about experiences,
you're talking about experiences
from people who are 100% credible.
The bulletproof,
only that,
but if you have the,
the former minister defense,
a candidate say that
he checked out with a u
s air force general that in fact there
was an accident that happened in New
Mexico in 1947 which people call Roswell.
And that what Phillip Corso Colonel Course
of wrote in his book the day after co
Roscoe was substantially correct.
Uh,
and,
and this is,
uh,
the honorable Paul Hellyer and he and
I did a press conference in Toronto a
couple of years ago and,
uh,
he is completely verified this.
So the,
the question is,
and then the same thing happened with
five star Admiral Lord Heal Norton.
I mean here he was the minister of defense
and he found out after the fact that
in fact an extra trust will vehicle
had landed at the bent waters,
uh,
earlier for space at
Rendlesham forest in England.
And we have multiple disclosure
project witnesses who were there.
And it came out recently that uh,
the Ministry of Defense in Great Britain
released the documents on that where
they had physical evidence that
this thing actually did land,
uh,
and left physical traces,
et cetera and so on.
So I tell people,
you know,
um,
usually in the New York Times say,
well,
we need two or three corroborating
witnesses to something,
particularly in three,
if it's a very controversial story.
I said,
yes,
but the disclosure project has
hundreds of these sort of people,
thousands of cases like this.
And we're not talking about just
people seeing something in the sky.
This is per event.
They don't mean like,
oh,
but we have,
we have an,
we have event,
we have multiple ones for this landing.
It knows from Fort,
we have multiple ones from
the might not North Dakota.
It had like how many do you have
a where there'll be some of them,
you know,
four or five,
six at one event.
And they are very
credible military people.
And so why isn't,
you know,
why isn't the,
the,
the lame stream news,
the mainstream news reporting this,
if you put together this
amount of information and
then the question becomes how
free is our media and how free is our
market and how free is our country?
Because I think there's more
corruption than people can imagine.
And uh,
I'm not a conspiracy theory person.
I deal,
wait a minute.
Yes you are.
No,
I'm not there.
You know,
I'm,
no,
I'm not,
but just be honest,
I just don't like the [inaudible]
island about Ufo conspiracy.
It was like,
it was the mafia conspiracy
of a criminal enterprise.
Yes.
But it's not a theory,
it's a fact.
So there's a big difference between,
um,
there obviously you're talking about a
Ufo conspiracy and energy conspiracy.
You're talking about
suppressing information.
He pulled conspire and
their own interests.
And if you're in Canada,
I don't know.
I know you don't like conspiracy theorist,
but okay.
When no,
I just don't see the term is used.
I think it's misused,
I think.
And I think that,
you know,
just waited.
It's loaded.
It's a loaded thing.
And it's like,
you know,
it's like when Larry King asked me,
do you believe I said,
well,
you know,
I believe in a lot of things
that you can't see improve.
But if I have 4,000 cases
where these things have landed,
if I have hundreds of
photographs and videotapes,
if I have dozens of top secret
guys who can corroborate this,
why is that a belief?
I mean,
you believe in God,
uh,
and some other things,
but I mean,
this is not a matter of belief.
Most people believe that.
I'll quote Neil degrasse Tyson who says
that eyewitness testimony is the least
reliable of all pieces of evidence.
It's right.
Um,
but what physical evidence do you
have that goes along with eye witness
testimony that you believe
is the most compelling?
Well,
I think the most
compelling that I've ever,
um,
it's something we're working on right now.
And,
um,
it remains to be seen if it's
going to be what we think it is.
And we're going to know fairly soon,
and I don't want to get ahead of myself,
but I was introduced to an
institute that acquired,
um,
a small humanoid being
about six inches in length.
Um,
this is in the trailer for serious,
I've seen this,
this little skeleton that's x rayed
and cat scanned and we're now doing the
genetic workup at the top university
in the world that's doing this,
um,
hope.
Pull that up,
right,
because it's a very freaky people
on Ustream and Vimeo can see this.
Uh,
we'll just,
we'll,
you know what,
let's just play the entire
trailer for you and,
uh,
get people excited about this movie.
Now,
who found this,
uh,
this alien being and where
did they acquire this thing?
It was,
uh,
I'm not at liberty to,
I'm still waiting to see if this person,
but it's an as,
it might be Horse Shit,
right?
It's a possibility.
No,
no,
I know.
All I'm saying is that
it isn't organic beam.
It is an organic paid is the cat scan
shows the lungs on the inside it has 10
ribs and not 12.
Um,
we have now proven from bone density
that it's at least several years old and
it's only six inches long.
Um,
so the,
the,
the tiny approved that from bone density.
That's medically we look at the epiphyseal
plates and the cow much calcium in
other words.
Right.
But isn't it why you're dealing
with a completely alien species?
No,
no,
no.
I'm saying if you were to go back,
if you're going to assume
that it's not easy,
then you look at it,
what would this be?
If it were human?
I see what you're saying.
Okay.
So you have to go through
an algorithm of an,
and it's a diagnosis of exclusion we could
say in medicine because if it's not a
miscarried or aborted fetus,
which is the size of what
this would be about 22 weeks,
um,
if it's not any known primate,
uh,
it's not a fossil cause it has
organic material in DNA material.
We've already extracted,
we clip the,
uh,
one of the ribs,
two of the ribs and I have gotten to
DNA material out of the rib of internal
Miro.
And so this is being processed
right now as we speak,
literally.
So if it was a human,
it would be several years old.
So that proves that it's not a human.
Uh,
there is no,
there's no form of dwarfism or any
other genetic anomaly known in the
literature,
uh,
according to the world's expert in this
area that would explain something of
this age that it's this and also
that has these abnormalities.
If you look at the skull,
if you look at the,
um,
the fact that has ribs,
there are new genetic syndromes
where you have 10 ribs.
If you see this thing in person,
I was the third person
to hold it and handle it.
Um,
and I did the,
I didn't say autopsy on it,
but I did the,
the,
the tests on it.
And how long had it been dead for you?
Had no idea that,
that we didn't get enough material from,
we didn't want to damage
this little thing too much.
So the carbon dating on
it will be the next step.
We wanted to be sure we had enough genetic
material and if we had to go back and
we didn't want to destroy,
uh,
in any way.
So we're,
we're working a scientific
algorithm on there.
This is actually the people,
the public who were supporting the film
serious or the reason why we were able
to do all these studies.
How is this,
um,
how this thing preserved,
you know,
but it was found in a very,
very dry desert area.
Um,
and it's just very desiccated.
It's very dry it out.
Um,
and uh,
it was not in any sort of preservative.
Um,
and now it died a traumatic death.
We know that behind the right mastoid
air cells behind your ear here,
that skull is crashed in and it's
a little asymmetrical on the jaw.
And the right humerus is
fractured through and through.
Um,
but,
uh,
and it happened at Mortimer shortly.
Purpose more than we think it was the
fatal blow to this particular being.
Now,
what is this beam?
Um,
when you look at it,
um,
almost every scientist
that has seen it goes,
it looks like an EDT.
Uh,
but we don't know.
All I'm going to say is that we're not
gonna be able to sit cause they're,
you know,
even the genetics,
there's no database to compare it to.
Now we have the whole human
genome to compare it to,
which is what we're doing right now.
And we have all the literature
that the world's expert in skeletal
abnormalities.
Uh,
the,
I mean,
the expert in the world looked at this
thing is that this is nothing that I know
of and that has ever
been seen on this planet.
Um,
and so the question then becomes,
what is it now?
It turns out it was found in an area of a,
the Atacama desert in Chile
that,
uh,
native peoples have
reports of these objects,
luminous objects going in and out
of the foothills of the Andes,
the famous famous for very famous,
very famous.
And um,
uh,
also in these remote,
native villages,
there are reports of
these very small beans,
upright humanoid type beans.
Said that also the area where the
constructed the VLT telescopic array,
one of the very large telescope I believe.
I think there are,
yeah,
cause it's very dark area and
there have been a lot of astronomy.
Uh,
and we also know a,
one of our witnesses who was manning a
facility on the Peruvian Bolivian border
that's not too far from this area,
was there in the early
nineties when we were using a,
uh,
Sdi star wars system to track Iti craft
and hit them with electromagnetic pulse
weapons.
And one was downed and crashed on
the Peruvian Bolivian border with
electromagnetic pulse weapons.
Yeah.
This is who did this.
I did the air force,
the army,
like,
do we know?
Yeah,
we know,
but I mean it's this group majestic,
you know,
if you were to talk to the general,
I briefed who's head of the
defense intelligence agency,
which is almost as big as the
CIA that's in the Pentagon.
He know anything about this.
So you say who's doing it?
It's,
it's not,
it's kind of almost not the correct
even way of framing it is to say,
uh,
you know,
when,
when senator annually
that he just passed away.
Wonderful senator from Hawaii,
you know,
he said there exists a secret
government with its own air force,
its own funding mechanism,
its own navy.
I'm quoting almost exactly.
And at the end actually is a great,
uh,
speech by the senator and it's because
he had run across that there that this
was going on.
So the question is,
who's running this?
Well,
they've gone off the reservation.
There's certainly no congressional
oversight or presidential oversight over
these rogue elements.
And I think that is a
threat to our democracy,
but it's also a threat to
our security in the world.
If what we've learned is true
for multiple military insiders,
that we have been attempting to target
these extraterrestrial vehicles and down
them.
How stupid is that?
And you're dealing with civilizations
that could turn the earth into a pink mist
floating through space in
a nanosecond and we're,
they're firing at them.
Why,
you know,
I mean does that,
but it,
you convinced that this happened.
Absolutely.
I absolutely know it is.
Cause I have too many insiders who,
who've been present when
we've done this sort of,
uh,
the weaponization of
electromagnetic signals.
What about disinformation?
D You have most of the information
out there is disinformation.
I would say ever hit you
like any this might be,
I have no,
no,
not when I'm telling you,
but uh,
have I ever been caught flat footed?
You almost.
Um,
and,
but you know,
we're very careful and I have to say,
you know,
as a doctor who got into
this sort of accidentally,
and then I was tutored and mentored by
some really good people in the military
and the intelligence community
who wanted me to do this.
And one of them is still to CIA,
Phd guy.
And he says,
you know,
someone needs to do this
because the politicians are
never going to do it within
these big corporations are
absolutely not going to let it out.
And this was back in the 90s.
And I said,
well,
what am I supposed to do?
And Yeah,
one of the interesting thing we,
after we put this briefing
together for Clinton and,
uh,
you know,
Lawrence Rockefeller,
uh,
I,
I put the concept together,
the best available evidence
and all these cases,
uh,
and then Lawrence Rockefeller hosted
a bill and Hillary Clinton at the
Rockefeller ranch and that it had
me out there shortly before that.
And Mr Rockefeller was the white hat
in the family who wanted to end the
secrecy,
unlike some of his,
his family.
Uh,
and,
and he,
so he said to me,
Oh,
one night I was at on his porch
on a deck in the grand Tetons,
the [inaudible]
ranch,
and,
and he said,
uh,
we really need you to
hurry up and do this.
And I said,
Oh,
Lawrence,
I'm just a doctor in North Carolina.
I'm working in an er,
you know,
he says,
no,
you have to do it.
I said,
no,
I Lawrence,
you have to get these guys to do.
He says they will never do it.
And I said,
Lawrence,
for God sakes,
you're old,
you're rich and you're Rockefeller.
He says,
no.
the implications of this are so vast and
so profound that no aspect of life will
be unchanged when it comes out.
I said,
yes,
Lawrence,
that's why it's secret.
And then he said to me,
well,
that means those folks
aren't going to do it.
And then,
you know,
before that,
as shortly after that,
and I had this,
um,
meeting with the CIA director and,
and,
and one of the president's friends
came to my house and this was a very
disturbing story.
I'm sitting at the
table with my four kids,
four daughters,
and this man who is very close
friends with the president,
uh,
Clinton says to me,
um,
well,
you know,
they're very supportive of what you've
recommended in this white paper.
I said,
great.
He says,
but they're not going to do it.
I said,
why not?
He says,
they're convinced that if the
president steps into this too hard,
he'll end up like Jack Kennedy.
And I started laughing,
thinking,
what a load of nonsense.
And he stopped me.
He says,
no,
they're serious.
I said,
well,
don't say this in front of the kids.
So we went to the library in my house,
um,
after dinner,
and I said,
what are you talking about Kevin?
And he said,
they really think this is too dangerous.
I said,
well,
what am I supposed to do?
What am I chop liver?
And he looked at me and he says,
yeah,
you're expendable.
So I've always viewed myself as the kind
of the throwaway guy and all of this.
I'm in a sense that these guys,
you know,
the,
the folks who have enormous
political power and corporate power,
uh,
even the ones who
support this very avidly,
and there's a lot of them,
um,
they don't want to stick their necks out,
but I'm confused.
Okay.
Why would they kill Bill Clinton if Bill
Clinton came out and said that we may
have evidence that there might be some
intelligent life out there in the world
or the universe.
She goes,
you know,
it's like the rem song.
It's the end of the world as we know it.
Because if that,
if that happens when that happens,
people would panic.
No,
no,
no.
The public isn't going to panic over
this unless it's couched in a stupid way.
Well,
the public definitely will panic if the
president comes out and says there's Ufo
is and then it gets whacked.
Hmm.
That would lead to panic.
Yeah,
but there's a bigger problem if the
president doesn't have control access over
these projects.
He didn't want to talk about it
because then it shows the fact that our
democracy has been side lined
as Eisenhower warned us.
I mean,
the reason I said,
look,
I mean Eisenhower was not military.
It was a five star general.
I have a phone.
You don't know the story.
Just fill people in on
the speech that he made.
Was he an active sitting president
leaving the last day of his presidency?
He basically said,
but where the military industrial
complex and this is the dangers.
And,
and he said,
the dangers of this enormous power
will be a threat to our democracy
and our way of life.
Now the reason he said that
is that between 1954 and 1960,
61,
when he was leaving office,
it was on his watch that the military
industrial complex reorganized under the
Rockefeller Commission of 1956.
And Eisenhower lost complete
control over these projects.
I have a lieutenant colonel who was on
the plane with Jack Kennedy flying to
Berlin when he gave the
I am a Berliner speech.
And um,
and Jack Kenny was talking
about this Ufo issue,
but he turned to this guy who was
kind of the chief steward for,
for Air Force One who,
who I know.
And he said,
uh,
I know about this,
but the whole matter does the
President Kennedy saying this,
the whole matters out of my hands.
And I don't know why.
And this guy was stunned.
In fact,
I'll tell you,
there's a kind of a gruff colonel,
air force guy who was crying as he told
the story because it hit him that there
had been sort of a silent,
silent coup d'etat on this issue.
And,
um,
one of the problems in Washington when
I meet with people who are part of a
powerful committees and,
and politicians is that,
um,
you know,
kind of,
they're kind of viewed as
place holders that come and go.
The mainstream media is really bread
and circus where they just keep wanting
people to be entertained with shock,
can dribble.
Um,
the question becomes,
how are you going to get this story out?
And that's why,
I mean a few years ago I left medicine,
uh,
which was a hard thing for
me to do because I mean,
I really love taking care of,
you know,
real emergencies.
And Trump,
did you do that for that
was in that er 10 years.
I was chairman of emergency
medicine and you know,
the problem became for me,
um,
the world's in an emergency.
So I said,
I'm an emergency doctor and I know an
emergency when I see one and we're in deep
trouble and so someone has to do this.
And,
but before I did that,
what you have to understand
is I went to everyone I could.
I mean,
I went to these powerful people.
I went to the UN and I went
to the British government,
the Ministry of Defense.
Um,
and basically none of them doubted.
This was all true.
Frankly.
This is what people need to understand.
There was no laughter in the room.
They took it very seriously,
but they didn't want to
stick their necks out.
And a friend of mine,
who's a big business guy,
he say,
well,
you know,
the way the world works now,
everyone wants to be first to be
second when it's something tough.
Okay.
I've always felt that something
along the lines of alien contact,
if they did have information,
there's no reason to let people
know unless it's unavoidable.
I always felt like unless they were just
going to try to do some damage control
and redefine what's happening,
I didn't,
I wouldn't think that they
would ever come out about it.
It just doesn't seem like it would be
something that would be advantageous to
just start telling people about Ufos.
Th th the idea is always that the
government is our daddy and then our
government's looking out for us.
But the evidence points
time and time again to that,
that that's horse shit and that's
not really what's going on.
But you know,
my military,
yeah.
Boys who made the point years
ago that because so many people,
I mean between five and 10% of the
public have seen one of these objects,
many of them,
very close range.
Let's get back to that because this is
what we had talked about before when we
got onto this.
People think the earth
is 10,000 years old.
Um,
I think most of what
people see is bullshit.
I think most,
yeah,
no question about that.
Most,
uh,
sightings.
I,
I did a show once for cvs
called game show in my head,
and it was a,
a hidden camera game show.
We'd put it an earpiece in people's
head and we were sending him out to the
street and a,
they didn't know what they had
to do until they got there.
And one of them,
we said,
okay,
see that camera over there?
That's where that works for you.
There was a big news camera,
you're a news reporter and there was
just a Ufo sighting right above Hollywood
boulevard.
The problem is the witness took off.
So you need to grab someone who wasn't
there and have them become a witness.
Tell them exactly what you need to
tell them to get them to do this,
get them to lie on camera,
then you need to get them to tell you
that they were abducted and probe.
And I'm Sarah and we got
people to do it like that.
It was,
yeah,
no,
I have no doubt,
but he was full of shit.
Yeah,
you can't,
you can always do that.
But I'm talking about high
level military and the residual,
I
mean,
for example,
um,
we have multiple,
uh,
air,
pilots for commercial
airlines and the air force.
Uh,
and this is one of the really
great cases we have by the way,
the Japan Airlines case over Alaska,
uh,
in the 80s.
And the guy who was in charge
of investigations for the FAA,
he was third from the top
during the Reagan era.
He actually left that agency and brought
the originals with him and gave them to
us of the radar tracings of this
thing that was the size of like 10,
seven,
47.
It's moving in a nonlinear
way over the skies.
It was on civilian radar,
which way it was on military radar.
They scrambled f 16 jets.
It was on their radar
and the Japan Airlines,
seven 47 pilot has testified to it.
And we have all of that in this case.
Heard of this.
All right.
So,
so when we brought all that
forward and this guy came for,
he says,
I'm one of these high level government
officials who actually has seen all of
this and has handled it,
but no one's asking the right questions.
So when you pull all that together,
and then of course there
will be events like the,
this thing that happened in Phoenix where,
you know,
eventually the governor of Arizona,
five Simonton came out later
and at the time he ridiculed it,
but he had actually
seen it came out later,
10 years later in 2007 said,
yeah,
that was an EDT craft almost certainly.
And I saw it and tens of thousands of
people in the Phoenix area saw it and it
was photographed and it was on radar
and there were very trained people.
So,
you know,
you have to ask the question how
many things like that have to happen?
And,
uh,
you know,
on the other hand,
the things that we have in physics,
uh,
that are,
that are inferred through
indirect measurements,
like black holes or articles that belief
and faith or even the Big Bang theory.
But when you have all of this,
and this is not just someone
on Hollywood boulevard,
he's making stuff up.
We have dozens,
thousands of people,
we have radar cases,
you have all this.
And so a lot of this is what's
going to be in the film serious.
And because what I said to people is that
the fact that people haven't seen this
evidence,
it doesn't mean that it doesn't exist.
It does exist.
I,
um,
and I agree with you.
There are a lot of people who will see
things and it will be a planet rising or
it'll be a,
a meteor or it'll be military aircraft,
a satellite or it'll be a com.
Now this is the other part of this.
There are a lot of things that are
Ufo sightings that are very legit.
And that's why I don't like the word Ufo.
There are two categories of Ufo shows
that once you eliminate all the nonsense
you're talking about,
and they're the ones that are Etvs,
which is what they're called,
the NSA extraterrestrial vehicles.
And then there are the ones that are
the electromagnetic devices we've been
building since the 50s and um,
if,
if people think that propulsion and
energy systems stopped in the forties,
they need to think about this,
list it back for a minute.
Your car is running on an
internal combustion engine circa
mine is because I'm a man.
Okay.
And I don't drive a and sissy hybrid.
Yeah,
there you go.
I'm not driving a Prius.
It makes no noise.
Yeah,
you should have a thousand words power,
electric one.
And then you'd really have
some powers is too futuristic,
man.
I need led Zeppelin on the radio.
I need a little seventies in my life.
Yeah,
well nobody,
I mean this,
you know,
and the jet engine people think
that we're flying around jet.
So I came out here from DC,
that's 1930s rockets,
1940s for Navon Brown does,
do people really think there've been
no breakthroughs in energy physics?
Well since the forties,
people absolutely know that we've
been working on things like that.
But to bring up what you brought up
earlier about the governor of Phoenix,
just to point out that
the governor of Alaska,
Arizona rather the governor of Alaska,
Sarah Palin was one of those people that
believe the earth is less than 10,000
years old.
So just because you're a governor or
something doesn't mean you're on the ball.
And second of all,
um,
I had friends that were in Phoenix and uh,
one of them very credible guy told me
he saw some giant black triangle flying
motionless over the sky.
He said it was bigger than
several football fields.
He said it made no noise and it blocked
out the the stars and flew over and he
said everyone in his neighborhood
was shitting their pants.
It was enough to me that I would go,
wow,
there's something.
There's too many people
that saw something.
He cute,
get attribute certain
things to mass hysteria.
But that was one of them that
I've found to be very strange.
But I never heard any photographs.
You say photograph,
we have amazing photographs and video.
They're going to be in the film.
Serious.
You don't have them anywhere else.
So I didn't go to see online.
You're holding them back.
No,
no,
no.
They're,
they're out there.
A doctor [inaudible] who's a medical
doctor also took some of them.
There's other video
photos of the crafts.
Yes.
The actual one.
So what should we,
if we want to look for one right now to
put in this show right now we're online.
Who Does he look for?
Um,
I guess you'd go to a Dr.
Lynn [inaudible] side.
I don't remember.
I spell her name.
I pull that up Brian and see what
image she has Google on there.
I've never heard that
there's been photographs.
Oh yeah.
What,
what does the photo show?
It shows exactly what people described,
a formation of lights that were moving
together in a massive sort of the
formation.
Right.
And the government said that those were
flares cause a couple hours later when
they couldn't contain
the news story on this,
I was there when this happened.
By the way,
you were in Phoenix.
Did you see it?
Yeah.
What'd you see?
What you,
what you just described now you when the,
why was I there?
Yeah.
Did you get your spider call to Batman?
Whatever.
The fucking,
the thing that Ufo just
appears over your house,
like the bat sign.
Remember when he's in trouble,
we need to send Batman.
Oh,
they do?
No,
they don't.
I was actually there,
uh,
at a digital lab that was being
loaned to us to put together,
coincidentally,
we're not coincidentally to put together
the best photos and videos to give to
Congress that I was briefing
in April of [inaudible] 97.
So in March of [inaudible] 97 I had
gone there and there was a guy who had a
digital laboratory who said,
look,
we'll let you use Harlow equipment
and assemble this and we'll help you.
Um,
and he'd worked a lot with the military.
And so I had collected photos and videos
from all over the world and governments
from all over the world,
which we call the best available evidence
and put what I was putting it together
because in April we were holding a closed
briefing from members of Congress who
wanted to know,
and this when people like
Congressman Dan Burton,
who was chairman of the House government
reform and Oversight Committee,
came in a whole lot of other people
from the Pentagon and vice president's
office and whatnot.
Um,
and,
uh,
so I was there then when that happened
and someone came running into the lab
saying,
my God,
while we're here trying,
there's all,
there's this going on.
And it turned out it was on
the news that night in Phoenix.
Now,
interestingly,
the national news,
they didn't pick up on it until June.
This happened in March,
which is very interesting.
Um,
why did that get held back?
But it,
you know,
and so there,
there are so many people
who saw it and this,
this was huge.
Whatever this object was,
it was not the size of like a seven 47,
uh,
seven 47,
you know,
you probably could put
dozens of them inside the,
the volume of this thing.
It was huge.
I found it interesting that
the stories were very similar.
So one of the things that
I found most interesting,
I uh,
watched some stuff online and then
when I spoke to my friend who lives in
Phoenix and he told me what he saw,
I was like,
wow,
you're talking about like at least six
or seven people that tell them the exact
same story of seeing this
exact same sort of thing.
Now these are the images
that you're talking about.
These are the,
just the,
the whatever,
the red lights that are in the sky.
I think the video is
probably more impressive.
Uh,
being that the video shows these things
essentially hover for a long period of
time and a much longer than really
should be attributable to parachutes and
flares.
It doesn't really make any sense
cause parachutes and flares.
They don't really move that slow.
When you,
you know,
you watch a guy jumped out of a,
um,
uh,
a plane with a parachute,
the parachute.
So you know,
they,
they s drive,
they slow your fall down,
but they don't make you suspect.
No.
And we know,
we know how those kind
of flares occur mean,
but the people who were directly under it,
and it moved not just
over this part of Phoenix,
it moved all the way from outside
Flagstaff through the valley and then down
towards Tempe.
Now how did you do about it?
You were there working.
Did you hear about it?
Did you,
there was a guy that ran into the lab
and who had actually been in the military
so you wouldn't believe what's going on.
So,
um,
so yeah,
I was there that night and 1997,
March of [inaudible] 97.
Yeah.
Now,
what's equally interesting,
if you look at this now,
the Bill Jin Air Force
cooperated with me very,
very nicely back in the early
nineties and late eighties.
You may have remembered there was this a
wave of things that happened in eastern
Belgium where there were these
massive triangles that were about,
uh,
800 feet on each side that
were photographed radar
traced chase by f sixteens
and on the,
and we have all this and the head of the
Belgian air force actually showed the
radar of one of these objects going
from hover to several thousand miles per
hour,
straight up into space,
way outside the envelope of any
normal conventional propulsion system,
the video,
this radar radar radar of it.
And we,
and we have that.
So you know,
the question becomes how many of these
cases do you need to have before you say
there's something out there.
And,
and I think this is what I,
the problem is that on this subject,
the ridicule around it and that the
disinformation and the crazy stories that
are out there is what dominates
the serious pun intended.
Perhaps the serious stuff really gets
left on the cutting room floor by most
movie directors and media
and even on the Internet.
It's very hard.
And I think the pick your way through.
It's very difficult what I've tried to do.
And then it's not that I've
done a perfect job of it.
I've done the best I
can with a lot of help.
Um,
but remember,
we've never been funded.
We're all volunteer effort.
Um,
and so what we've tried to do is get
people who have the really good stuff from
governments come forward and share it.
And this is why,
you know,
when the Space Agency of France
released a lot of their documents,
uh,
after I,
I was having some meetings in
France and with some of the seniors,
can't say it both ways
to the France of France.
It was France when I was there.
And when it's here,
it's France.
There you go.
And you know,
there's an admiral that,
that works with us in France
who's a wonderful guy.
And,
um,
he's an MD and a phd in an Amaryl and,
and you know,
he knows all this is very real.
And,
and so eventually the
French government really,
I believe it was about a hundred
thousand pages of documents.
I'm on all of this.
And,
and,
and now,
uh,
since the disclosure project
launched it 10 or 12 years ago,
there are 14 countries
who've opened up their files.
Now,
Chris,
the United States isn't because the
United States is managed differently.
Um,
on this issue.
It's a compartment.
It unacknowledged for Soviet Union
has actually been pretty open more,
more recently in more recent
times about the first fell apart.
Not so much now,
but when it first fell apart.
We have a,
have a great dossier of KGB cases
and files and also military.
And in fact,
uh,
some of the cosmonauts that
had had encounters with these,
I pulled together in 1995 for a meeting
with some of our astronauts like Edgar
Mitchell,
um,
to have a meeting out here in California.
Um,
so,
you know,
there were some,
some really solid cases out of the Soviet
Union or Mitchell claim to have had a
personal experience.
No,
no,
he's just investigated it and has
concluded that this is all very real.
And he,
he,
he did come with me.
I invited him to the briefing.
We set up for the head of intelligence
for the Joint Chiefs of Staff,
the Pentagon.
Um,
and I think it was a very interesting for
him to have learned that the people at
that level were shaken to
their foundations because
they concluded this was all
real.
But when they made inquiries,
they were being lied to and denied access.
And so this,
this brings up this question,
how to,
who's running this show?
And,
and who's over who the Fox is a garden,
the hen house,
and I,
and this is exactly,
it goes back to Eisenhower's warning,
but you know,
we're 50 years into that era now.
And so half a century later,
as big of a screw up as it was in 1961
when Eisenhower warned us about it,
it's 10 times worse than that now.
And,
and so much so that I have concluded that
the way we change the dynamic on this
is that the people lead,
the leaders will have to follow.
We do the disclosure,
we bring out these technologies,
we set up teams to make contact,
and we just bypass the government.
The evidence that you have this,
uh,
or possible evidence of this,
alien life before that,
this is a more recent thing.
This is fairly recent,
right?
Before that,
what was the most compelling piece
of physical evidence that you've ever
encountered?
I would have to say that it's the,
it's these really well documented
complex cases that involve,
uh,
documents,
radar cases with photographs and multiple
corroborating credible witnesses such
as playlists,
landing sites.
We do,
and I actually,
uh,
we have been given materials from where
the sites of land in delivery anomalous.
Uh,
what a great case that's in the French
files that they released in the Japan was
a coach Japan this through
space agency like NASA,
um,
release was the pro bono case of 1981,
I believe,
when a one of these objects landed
in a lavender field of all places.
So we're blessed to smelled.
Awesome.
Yeah,
well everyone's a commercial
lavender farm and I'm so cool.
Um,
and it was wee hours in the
morning and this thing lands,
the farmer comes out and,
uh,
is this,
disc shaped craft hold?
Um,
uh,
I,
I think it was in the 50 foot diameter
range and there were these little beans
outside picking lavender.
Now this sounds crazy,
like a amount of science
fiction.
How little like you're a little guy.
No,
no.
These are
from what I remember like four feet,
five feet in that range and then it,
but it left this spot
where it hit landed and it,
there were anomalies,
electromagnetic,
uh,
sort of,
radiation into the soil.
And this was actually studied
by the French government,
occluded to be an absolutely real case,
just like the bent waters,
Royal Air Force Base case in England was
determined to be an authentic case of a
landing.
So these sort of landing cases
that have also now at the time,
um,
there weren't many people coming forward.
Now we have all these military
people coming forward corroborating.
They were there,
they saw this and now the documents are
getting released from the UK and France.
But in the United States
it's still a black hole.
Now we're going to play your,
your trailer for the upcoming film series.
You got to pull that.
Brian,
is it cute?
All the way through because I know we
said 2012 with the world still burning oil
and gas and coal.
When we have had all the information
we need to have had a completely new
civilization.
Dr. Steven Greer is an absolutely hero
and the councils of government.
We must guard against the acquisition of
unwarranted influence whether sought by
the military industrial complex,
you know,
hundreds of billions of dollars
public of the little noise.
All right,
sit down and shut up.
I was told to talk not to listen.
I'm learning to listen.
The primary purpose is to train people
to understand these other civilizations
and their cultures.
I don't give a God damn what
anyone else says about it.
I saw that like who do you fel without
them looking at you like you ain't
wrapped too tight and I was a part of
the United States air force cover up for
18 years.
What we are attempting to achieve as a
device which the foods the perpendicular
force of gravity,
when we look at our data,
we lost 7% the weight.
We now have the technology
to take the t home.
The consciousness is at once the most
familiar thing to us and the most
mysterious.
It doesn't take much effort.
Did you just clear your mind?
People are afraid of
looking at technology.
All Brown stuff got basically
suppressed for many years.
Can you got murdered?
Problem is not proving that you oppose
exists is when you begin to expose the
energy and propulsion system
behind how they're getting here.
Wow.
That little thing freaked me out.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I don't mean to sound callous,
but being a,
you know,
doctor,
I've seen so many worse things,
but it's actually fascinating.
Fascinating.
I mean freak me out and
not that it's a dead body.
I've seen things.
It freaked me out that that
might be a life form by the way.
He was a life form.
We know for a fact it was
a life form what it was,
what we're investigating.
And I think that,
you know,
one of our witnesses who
was on a retrieval team,
um,
uh,
of retrieving extra terrestrial bodies
from craft that we had targeted,
um,
uh,
you know,
was talking about the fact that there
are many different species that had been
cataloged over the years.
And,
and at one point,
I think it was in the late sixties,
there were like 68 or 69
or something in that range.
Um,
you know,
uh,
if you look at space
and look at the stars,
probably every stable star
system has planets around it.
They're,
they're discovering.
And there's the likelihood that there's
an enormous diversity of life out there
is,
it's a statistical certainty,
uh,
even the conventional astronomers and,
and,
uh,
the Drake formula.
What support that?
The question is,
you know,
have they gotten here?
Well,
your most probably wouldn't be able to.
It's just like we weren't for
thousands and thousands of years,
but is there,
there's such Hubris to think that,
you know,
we're at the pinnacle of the technology
on earth in 2013 and we're not.
And I think that the,
and I think that,
you know,
when you begin to look at the progression
of technology once you reach him or
breakout point as we have
in the last century here,
in fact,
most of the big breakthroughs
in technologies,
no one knows about.
They exist,
but they're in a classified project.
And that's,
I think as big or a bigger story than
the [inaudible] story is the fact that
there is a cabal of,
of,
as I said,
sociopathic misanthropic folks who have
decided they're macro economic grip on
power needs to be maintained through
this sort of ruthless secrecy and where
they keep from the
public this information,
not because they think people are going
to hurl themselves off the Brooklyn
Bridge because we're not
alone in the universe.
But because when this comes out
and this information comes out,
it means that the sciences already exist
so that we can get off oil and gas and
coal.
And you know what a
Goldman Sachs guy said,
that's a $600 trillion not you're
cracking right there trillion.
And because if you look at
all the oil in the ground,
the coal in the ground,
the commodities trading,
the petrodollar system,
the utilities,
the internal combustion engines,
all of that is defunct,
extinct stuff or should be.
And so here we are
cannibalizing this planet,
um,
for no good reason except that there's
a of folks and you look at the,
the,
the sort of centralization of wealth
and power there is in the world now.
It's the most extreme it's ever
been in human history right now,
right this minute,
this incident.
So,
you know,
there's 200 to 300 individuals and
corporations that have over half the net
worth of the world.
You know the guy in the beginning of your
video that says that you're a genius,
David Wilcock.
Do you know who that guy is?
I know who he is.
Do you know that he also thinks that he's
Edgar Casey reincarnated and shows you
pictures of,
I have no idea.
That's news to me.
You're Casey's friends and how his
friends look like Edgar Casey's friends.
You ever watched any
of that guy's lectures?
No,
I haven't.
Yeah,
I mean some of the team interviewed him,
but I don't want to do it a little louder.
They might want to do a little of,
and with that one,
I'm not saying that anything else
in your documentary is bullshit,
but that guy makes my
radar detector go off.
Um,
the,
the evidence that this,
uh,
this technology has been suppressed.
Is there,
is there evidence that that like
this free energy technology has been,
there's a huge amount of evidence and
you reveal this in this documentary
whole document trail.
And one of the things we got some years
ago was a demand from the Department of
Defense to the FBI that they turn over
the secret papers of Nikola Tesla that
were stolen.
And we have this document and um,
you know,
what happened to them and
what were they trying to hide?
Um,
the Federation of American scientists,
a very big mainstream organization in
Washington that has a national security,
uh,
research project associated with the
Federation of American scientists came out
about two years ago with a
report that there were 5,000,
135 patents that had been seized
under the National Security Act.
And that some of these
things were energy related.
One of them in 1971 was only a,
uh,
a solar photo voltaic generator.
You know,
we're from sunlight to electricity,
photovoltaic,
um,
that was more than 20% efficient.
Now you can't even get that now.
Um,
but meaning there was probably like 40,
50% turning sunlight directly into
electricity and it had a national security
order slapped on it.
And this mainstream scientific groups,
it's,
how could that be a threat
to national security?
It would have been a threat to the
domination of oil and coal and the
petrodollar system.
So,
you know,
this is not a conspiracy theory.
There are entities that have conspired
and you look at the wealth and power
behind these entities.
I mean,
people have been killed
for a lot less than this.
It really is.
That is such a loaded word,
that conspiracy,
it's unfortunate that
it's necessary to use a,
because it's been so co-opted.
Well,
I,
I think it's really more about special
interests in cartels always acting in
their interests.
And if you've got the power,
you're going to use it and you know,
here and here,
and here's the problem if the
people allow it to happen.
And I was just reading an article in,
uh,
in the new republic about this,
um,
that you,
whether you're,
you know,
letting Saddam Hussein or,
or the Libyan dictator Muammar
Qaddafi or whatever it is,
or you have to give them that power.
We give the power to the government
ultimately by our pacivity.
And so ultimately,
I,
you know,
I'm not one of these people
who runs around saying,
oh,
well,
you know,
there are these boogie men that are
doing everything and we're just hapless
creatures.
If we're allowing it,
if we're not part of the solution,
we're part of the problem.
If we're gonna,
if we're allowing it by our inaction and
pacivity cause we're one of the bread
and circus people sitting around eating,
you know,
Cheetos and watching Jay Leno,
which is fine,
but if that's all we're doing and
we're not trying to fix this problem,
then you know,
obviously the passivity of the public and
our politicians who don't want to risk
their career or danger
in that power vacuum,
you're going to have these
sorts of people step and,
and,
and I think there's a power vacuum,
uh,
that existed for a little
while after World War II.
They gave an entry to these folks.
And um,
I think that it will continue
for as long as we let them do it.
I think it's pretty obvious when you
look at the fact that this is the age of
information where information is being
distributed more freely and more easily
than ever before.
Right?
Yet,
this is also the age where the government
is continuing to attack the bill of
rights.
Continuing to slowly but surely restrict
our rights and civil liberties and make
it so that if they deem you a
threat to the nation in any way,
shape or form,
they can essentially detain you.
They don't have to do anything legal,
they don't have to contact your family.
This is all stuff that's being passed now.
And that seems to me to point to the
fact that they're looking at this w w w
what is the,
what's where,
where's it going?
What's,
if you look at it on a graph,
if you look at it,
if you project the future,
well,
it's going towards some
ultimate free information space.
And if it gets to that,
then it's going to be revealed exactly
how much fucker he's been going on for
all these decades and how much craziness
has been going on behind the scenes.
And it's going to come to a point in time,
or the government's gonna have to be
accountable for where all the money goes
every year in tax dollars.
And right now they're not.
You give them your tax dollars,
you don't get a receipt,
you don't know what the fuck happens.
There's a con congressional
budget meetings and they,
the Senate,
you know,
gets together and the president puts out
his plan and the financial people get
involved.
But what,
how much access do we actually
have as to where your doctor,
Steven Greer's financial
records are your tax dollars go?
Almost nothing.
Oh,
we don't know.
And even the folks who,
uh,
I know an auditor in it for the federal
government who audits Northrop Grumman,
and he said,
one of the problems is that once you get
to a compartment compartment it project
that's eyes only and it's unacknowledged,
they're not going to tell you anything.
They won't even acknowledge it exists.
So how,
is there any check and balance on that?
It's essentially a dictatorship.
Yeah.
When it gets to that,
really,
you're,
you're essentially dealing
with a dictatorship.
It's just dressed up as a democracy.
But their ability to act as complete.
We there,
there they have total impunity.
They can do whatever the fuck they want.
They don't,
they don't,
they don't have to listen
to me if we let them.
Here's the other problem with that,
you know,
is that the,
the macro economic system,
you know,
we're supposed to be
a free market economy.
Well,
how free can the market be if there've
been decades of confiscation and
suppression of these advanced,
uh,
trans dimensional energy devices in
the so called over unity free energy
devices.
And if the,
if that's going on,
a can completely lays to waste the
whole concept of a free market.
So yeah,
it's a free market if you want to tinker
around the edges and come out with an
iPhone and five instead of
an iPhone four or you know,
whatever version of this and that.
But let's not forget that your
computer that you think is so cool,
you're charging it off a grid that's a
18 hundreds coal fired power grid for the
most part.
And so,
you know,
we really have to wake up to the fact
that our society has been held back
retarded.
I'm really seriously by
this kind of secrecy.
And so the secrecy is actually
becoming a threat to our continued,
not just our liberty,
but it's an existential
threat to the planet.
And Moreover,
it keeps forcing all these unintended
consequences where we stay,
uh,
encamped in the Middle East.
And you know,
the buzzword in Washington because of
our vital national security interests.
Well,
that's code for oil.
Just forget the BS.
That means oil because you say,
well,
what about Israel?
Israel has two or 300 nuclear
weapons and they might,
I live there for three years.
Believe me,
when I tell you the thing,
they care of this.
I mean,
you know,
if,
if they,
if there's an existential
threat to Israel,
you know,
they can handle it.
They don't need big brother America there,
but don't they mean,
isn't it,
don't they get a tremendous amount of
funding from us and weapon and they get
funding.
But I'm just saying we don't,
that's not the reason we were an all
those vast areas of the Middle East.
It's because of the oil intercourse.
And,
and you know,
and this becomes a question of,
uh,
why?
Well,
because if you have a device
that would fit on the table here,
that run your house when you don't
have to be on the grid or your car,
put it in the boot of your car and
you have enormous amount of power,
electric,
how would that work?
Um,
those are called,
uh,
zero point or quantum vacuum,
electromagnetic generators.
And basically through
very high voltage systems,
you create a vector into this baseline
energy field that it really holds the
universe together.
And you know,
they start talking about the Higgs field
and the negative energy that matter of
the universe.
But for years it's been proven that the
zero point energy field exists through
the,
what's called the castle mirror effect.
And don't get into the
Arcana of the physics of it.
But this was published
in mainstream journals.
The question is,
how do you tap it and can you,
and the answer is yes,
and it happened,
but they keep suppressing scientists
and inventors who come up with it.
There was a man that I know who worked
at Lawrence Berkeley labs and he was
using a coil to ray around a Barium
titanate crystal and using very high
voltages,
um,
with a
certain hertz,
certain pulses.
He was able to get 10 times more energy
out than was going in because the
Chrysalis structure was tapping into this
zero point energy field that is in the
fabric of space and time.
So there's an enormous amount of power.
It's been estimated that every
cubic centimeter of space,
not outer space of space in this room
has enough energy to run the earth for a
day if you could tap it.
So the question becomes,
if you can do that,
you're not going to need to have your
car filled up at a gas station or utility
to con ed or whoever it is.
And uh,
those sort of interests at Trump,
the technical ones to
technological issues.
Um,
I believe it can be fixed.
It's the strategic issue.
That's the problem.
I'm going to stop you because I
need to know about this experiment.
Where was this taking place?
This is this pure reviewed?
Is this something that has been,
it was confiscated a,
the man that had this happen,
um,
it's a physicist and a,
some goons broke into his lab,
broke it up at the experiment and then
basically took him and put him in a
mental hospital in the hospital
for awhile where this happened.
Lawrence Berkeley labs
in the eighties okay.
So seventies or eighties.
I don't know exactly what he did.
And is it reproducible?
Yeah.
I I think why has no
one ever reproduce this?
It doesn't make any sense because you
have to have a whole lot of specialized
equipment to do it right.
And people have tried what the hero
now here to here is getting to the,
really,
the reason I'm doing this film is that
100% of the proceeds from it are going to
go into build a new energy lab.
So all this stuff that
we've collected can be done.
I think with the intelligence we've
gathered in between one and two years,
we will come out with at
least a generation 1.0 of
these energy systems because
I have thousands of pages of
documents on this and many,
many physicists who
worked in these programs,
but you've got to have
a properly equip lab.
You've got to have security,
you've got to have the
whole world watching,
and this would not be a secret project
like the skunk works at Lockheed.
This would be,
I would in my,
it'd be like this,
it'd be streamed.
So all the work going on in that lab,
the whole world's watching.
Okay.
Sorry,
because I don't think
you can do this secretly.
You know about this story.
How come you knew about this experiment
tapping into zero point energy,
but this is not common knowledge
amongst nuclear physicists.
This is not something that's
discussed in the mainstream news.
This is not something that you can find
information online and any credible
source.
No one has [inaudible].
It seems to me that if there was an
experiment that tapped into such an
unbelievably unlimited
supply of energy like that,
it would be impossible
to keep this under wraps,
that you would keep the beak,
be able to keep the
conversation under wraps.
No,
that's not true.
And in fact,
if you go to the website,
serious disclosure.com,
there's a portal there to the energy
research and there are thousands of
documents and pages of stuff,
things that were reported in the
media and then they got confiscated in
shutdown.
But you're,
you're asking this question as if academia
and the media are operating freely,
none under the suppressive,
uh,
behaviors.
And,
and I thought,
man,
I'm asking the actually because
it just the nature of human curiosity
and an incredibly brilliant,
brilliant,
intelligent men that are
out there that study energy.
I would think that someone would
look into this and he examined it.
Okay.
You're,
well,
there is,
and in fact,
one of the people that we
had were funding for awhile,
um,
before he got threatened by a former
CIA director who went down to his skiff.
It's secure communication
intelligence facility.
Um,
was,
uh,
an understudy of William Bender
at the University of Washington.
He got threatened and
what they say in 1974,
I think it was 74,
he formed a company,
uh,
and he's a brilliant to one of the
most brilliant people I've ever met.
Um,
who,
and he had developed a,
these trans dimensional systems
using electromagnetic energy.
And,
uh,
some guys came in with a
national security order,
uh,
told him that they were
confiscating his equipment,
his device,
his notes,
and they were all going into the vault.
And this man's,
uh,
who I knew very well,
who stayed at my home and it still works
for 'em under contract with the CIA and
various groups.
Um,
he said that basically,
uh,
the intelligence community owns his soul
and that he can only do only so much it
take it take to provide
information and bring this out.
And uh,
you know,
people who think that doesn't happen
or living in very naive world.
This is 40 years ago though,
you're talking about.
Um,
and it would happen.
That was 40 years ago when
hit when the thing he started.
Then when he,
after I developed a relationship with him,
he checked with his intelligence
and what they called the shepherds,
his in his handlers in the
intelligence community.
They said,
yes,
you can work with Dr. Greer,
not on the propulsion stuff
that flies around like a Ufo,
but just when the energy
generation part of this.
And so we provided a grant
to him through my project,
the Orion project,
uh,
which is government limits,
his ability to do research
on specific topics.
Uh,
well he actually is on the payroll to
government now cause he was basically told
us this,
so you have no career at all.
And if he had disclosed what he had
been invented in 1974 under the national
security or he was hit with,
he would have been imprisoned.
So,
um,
and these exists,
you can look it up.
It's section one 81 81 of the patent
law and the National Security Act.
These national security
orders happen all the time.
So,
but who's authorized?
You think?
Oh,
President Obama or the or the Senate
Intelligence Committee knows that these
goons are out there doing this stuff.
No.
And so here's this brilliant guy,
but I mean,
he's not like he's Rambo.
I mean he,
he's an engineer and a physicist.
So he develops this stuff.
A bunch of guys come in
who are bad ass folks.
Okay.
And he's terrified.
And so then all these years
later it circles back around,
we get hold of him and what we say,
look,
okay,
here's,
you know,
some funds do this,
uh,
for us own a generation,
1.0 version of this something.
Uh,
and check with your intelligence folks.
And they cleared him about the time he
was beginning to put this thing together.
A former CIA director,
a bunch of goons came down in 2010,
this is two years,
three years ago,
threatened him,
threatened his family.
And so like,
how do I say,
you are not going to do this any
further and made it very clear.
Um,
one of the guides at the naval research
labs I've worked with for years who has
some of this information,
he was till we will kill you,
your wife,
your children,
and your grandchildren if
you step out of line on this.
So I don't think that,
you know,
in terms of dealing with this that you're
going to be able to do it under any
kind of where someone's
trying to do it quietly,
secretively,
it's going to have to be in plain sight.
So what you're saying is that several
people have tried to do this in the past
hundred every time and every time they
do it they're threatened and stopped from
doing it.
Right.
What specialized pieces of equipment
would be necessary to produce this zero
point energy field thing?
Well,
first of all,
um,
you know your,
your computer in lights who
are running on one 10 or 2020,
all right,
voltage,
the voltage is involved in these trans
dimensional physics is in the thousands
to millions of volts,
but it very low current.
And so you have to have special
analyzers and generators for that.
So,
I mean,
there is a science to this
and we understand it very,
very well actually.
Um,
but building up that lab,
I mean,
we looked into the equipment just,
is it like half $1
million just to do that?
Um,
and so what you have to do
is it seems like nothing,
if you're talking about half $1 billion,
they can bring newness.
That's just the equipment.
No,
no,
no.
This no,
no building,
no personnel,
no staff,
no nothing.
Just you know,
and the machine.
So,
but so I,
we estimate,
uh,
we have,
a budget for about a two year program,
around $6 million to put a lab together,
put these really brilliant people in it,
get the right equipment and built up
these experiments and do real science.
But the problem is you have people
off on their own doing this,
that stumble across this phenomenon
and they get shut down or threatened or
bought out.
Um,
then,
you know,
you had the folks who,
um,
will be,
instead of threatened,
they'll just be offered money.
You know,
so a lot of people,
uh,
Dr. Beard and tells this story of a man
that had one of these generators and,
and he was testing it and it was
a legitimate over unity system.
And the,
then the guy disappeared.
And the next time you saw the guy who
had a Ferrari in an Armani suit and the
guy never had a pot to pee in as it were.
And,
and,
and you know,
what we found with this is that a
lot of times folks will just say,
look,
you know,
we're going to buy this.
Uh,
and,
uh,
a lot of people don't believe that
happens and they think that's a conspiracy
theory.
It isn't a conspiracy theory.
And this is why the Federation
of American scientists,
when they said,
look,
there are 5,000,
135 or something like that,
patents that had been seized.
Most people don't know that those national
security orders can happen outside of
the patent process.
So even if you're not
going the patent route,
they can go in there and
just sees the damn thing.
Uh,
and what are you going to do?
They just seize it based on the idea
that it somehow or another threat,
well there you,
I mean it's,
it's Kinda like the flag in the Bible
and that you'd be wrap yourself in these
things.
It to do all kinds
of outrageous uh,
behaviors.
Yes.
But I mean you can say
it's national security,
but as this one document from
the Federation of American
scientists is how could
a solar voltaic system be a
threat to the national security?
It would be a threat to the special
interests that are calling the shots.
So the question becomes who's really
calling the shots on these sorts of
decisions?
Is it in the interest of we the people?
No,
it's in the interest of folks who,
who want to protect their cartels.
What is your take on,
um,
guys who have come clean before?
Guys like Dr Robert Lasar
cause that guy full of shit.
He's the guy from area 51 that came
back and said that he was a bright back
engineering,
some alien craft and very
compelling to listen to.
Very interesting guy.
Before I understand,
um,
Dr. Stanton Freedman questioned him and
in fact called him a fraud and said that
some of his educational
background was kind of made up.
Right.
But here's the problem with any case
where you hang it on one person like that,
um,
is very risky.
And that's why I've tried to resist that.
And then when we,
we,
when we started putting together,
uh,
the people who knew about the,
the nuclear facilities with
aircraft Ufo was coming over.
I didn't want one or two.
I want it half a dozen or a dozen.
And that's what we have.
But the more spectacular the cases,
if it hangs on one person,
the written,
and the other question is
where's the corroboration?
So I think that that's why
we try to focus on that.
Now,
I will say that the areas
out in the Nellis range and
nobody by the way cause it
area 51,
but this is to say that because somebody's
a poot Mesa s four s three s 12,
and actually this national reconnaissance
office document from the 1990s lists
those facilities there,
um,
properly,
you know,
um,
well that's after blackjack control
to a apply for additional land.
Before that they had denied it entire,
right.
Right.
They had to apply for additional land
because people were getting so close that
they could film a footage of some of
these crafts that they were experimenting
on.
And a,
that's not bullshit if you've ever seen,
oh,
the real one knows.
Yeah,
no one knows what those things were,
but the way they were
moving was extraordinary.
They moved unlike any craft that we know.
Um,
I would assume,
uh,
that if you look at what we're doing
today in all different parts of the world
with drones,
especially these drones that of
Hellfire missiles that you know,
can be fairly accurate when you
considering that they're being operated by
someone halfway across the world.
Right.
Um,
that this probably has something to do
with what they were working on back then
when they're making these things fly
around and do all these crazy turns right
just in the sky.
No,
because of the drones that are being
reported are conventional propulsion
systems,
either jets or what we're talking about
are things that are moving in a way that
is outside the envelope of
normal aerodynamic behavior.
In other words,
you cannot take something with a normal,
a propeller or a jet
engine and accelerated at 20,000 miles
per hour and make a right hand turn.
And we have photos and images
of these things doing this.
So when you're doing that,
that's going to,
you know,
your,
your brains are going to come out of
your nose if you're a pilot and even a
conventional object is going to be blown
to smithereens by the inertial forces
of that kind of a turn and deceleration.
I think so.
Are we talking about two
different things though?
You know,
I'm not talking about the,
it's a thing saying,
but you're talking about
things that had been seen.
It's in space.
No,
I'm talking about things
that had area 51 at area 51,
and also all over the world that had
been documented moving in this way.
Those are moving.
And I'm quoting actually of
General de Brouwer of the,
uh,
the Belgian air force chief who said
this is outside the envelope of any
conventional aerodynamic system.
I'm not questioning that,
but what I am saying is that the things
that I've seen as far as videos from
area 51 with these,
these,
uh,
unidentified objects,
whatever,
they were moving across the sky,
they weren't moving that fast.
They were oil.
They were moving conventional speed.
Oh,
that's convinced.
Well,
so that could be,
but I'm talking about the things that
I know that have been imaged out there,
including a daytime object.
We have a great video.
What do you,
what does this video
that you're showing us,
Brian,
what was that?
This is a low year 49 quad copters
and an outdoor formation flight that,
okay,
let me see that.
It's pretty,
pretty bad as the video.
This is a,
these are,
uh,
conventional.
Uh,
you could actually buy these,
right?
These,
uh,
I,
I don't,
I'm not sure.
Uh,
they,
Darpa was this Darpa Shit,
this is a ars electronica.
Oh yeah,
you can buy little miniature.
Yeah.
If you've never seen this,
what they can do now is
really extraordinary.
I mean,
this is a,
all these drones moving
or what do you call them?
What are the things are just
like little toys almost.
So they are,
but I'm sure it's,
a lot of people saw this
in the sky and was like,
oh my God,
what the fuck that and called it,
you know,
Ufo is how they move.
I mean,
this is really amazing stuff.
They move in a,
in a geometric pattern in
the sky that mimics galaxies.
All right,
cool.
So we know that there's some things that,
I mean,
these are obviously terrestrial crafts.
This is something,
look,
look what they're doing.
I mean,
that's amazing.
This is not ufs courses identified flying.
I mean,
not everything that people see that
they don't know what it is is a Ufo.
I mean it's an,
well,
it's unidentified to them
and it may be flying,
but you know what I'm talking about
things that are really quite amazing.
It's like this one photograph we have
of this triangle that's going like this
and it makes a right hand turn and go
and it's going in more of a staff or a
video photo.
Can we see this?
I want to,
uh,
it's,
I don't know where it's
going to be in the film,
but it's going to be in the film,
but it's,
it's available online isn't it?
I mean it must,
um,
I don't know.
I only so long as it's been around for,
I'll have to look it up made,
I don't have to cut of the film in here,
but you know,
this is one,
you know,
there are a number of these,
but this is a very
compelling piece of evidence.
Amazing.
Why wouldn't you that online immediately
and say,
hey,
you got to look at this.
This is a compelling piece.
I think it is online somewhere,
but I mean,
I just can't tell you where,
um,
you know,
we,
we have thousands of pages on our website.
You can go,
if you go to a serious disclosure.com
you can click through and there's a whole
photo gallery and all kinds of stuff.
Are we okay?
Go ahead and go.
I don't know if this particular
one is in that photo gallery,
but for example,
you look at the,
the Vancouver Island
photograph of a few years ago,
I don't even think it was in the
eighties daytime disc with a dome.
It is not Photoshop.
It was studied at Nasa Ames.
Um,
it's probably the clearest
photograph ever taken broad daylight.
And you know,
what is that?
Well,
you know,
it,
it's just like these ones from Belgium
where you have these photographs of these
big triangular objects and their photo
and video of those matching up with radar
cases in jet pilots chasing them.
I'm talking about those kinds of things.
Um,
there,
there's actually more than people
can imagine that's out there.
Okay.
So there's enough of these
things where if you look at,
uh,
B,
believe Michio Kaku said 5% of all Ufo
sightings are completely unexplainable
defined laws of physics and,
and may possibly be in his opinion,
something that we don't understand
possibly.
Cause that's the one I'm talking about.
The other stuff.
Yeah.
I'm curious,
what do you think they're doing here
since the $64 trillion question?
Yeah,
I think,
I think there are a number of things.
Number one,
I don't think they're new at all.
Um,
I,
I don't think there's a new phenomenon,
there's enough material out there from
ancient times that would indicate that
these objects have been
around since recorded history.
I mentioned this earlier in the show,
but secondly,
I think this stage of our evolution,
the civilizations are rather concerned
about our potential to destroy this
planet and ourselves,
but also the fact we're going into space.
We have not become peaceful.
And in the classified projects we have
things way beyond the international space
station so that we could become an
existential threat to other planets
potentially.
So I think that there
is a concern about that.
And I think that,
you know,
love your,
all these movies,
you know,
battle Los Angeles and Independence
Day and Blah Blah Blah avatar.
You know,
it's like,
well yeah,
and it's such,
to me it's like,
okay,
yeah.
It's like when I went to Wright Patterson
air force base where they had the,
the,
the blue room that,
that Barry Goldwater
tried center to go water,
tried to get in and uh,
you know the story.
Yeah.
What wasn't that,
but,
but the,
the thing is is that I'm hangry
teen Wright Patterson Air Force,
but yeah,
but this is a different thing.
At Wright Patterson Air Force base,
it was called the Blue Room.
Is that where supposedly the Roswell
wreckage was the air material command.
And then when I was there,
by the way,
very compelling piece of evidence and
it might've been something serious going
on other than a weather balloon.
The fact that two separate planes we
use to send this wreckage because the,
in case one of them went down,
right.
It was so historically significant.
I have that,
um,
that newspaper,
the Roswell daily record,
I have that page on my wall in my
house and I looked at it all the time.
It's a fascinating,
I mean it's,
it's essentially a press release by
the military saying we've recovered a
crashed disk before they pulled it back.
Yeah.
It's amazing because that's,
um,
that's a big statement,
you know,
I mean,
you look at all the
things that could've been,
they could've been wrong about like,
oh,
it could have been something else.
And the,
but the,
the fact that they came out and said
it's a crashed disk that had never been
done before,
that,
that really was one of the,
the,
the first,
I think some heads rolled
over that press release.
But uh,
cause they had to pull it back and they
did that ridiculous dog and pony show
where they brought out this shitty
looking aluminum boy kind of looks like a
mylar thing.
It's hilarious that,
that,
that's quite hilarious.
And the government.
I've always,
I mean,
if you just look at the history of
deception that the government has in,
in dealing with the American
public from the get go,
and whether it's with the Gulf of
Tonkin incident or whether it's the,
what happened with the,
the contrast and the Sandinistas using
taxpayer dollars and black ops from
selling cocaine in the ghettos of
Los Angeles to fund rebel armies.
If you just look,
you've got to know they're
not telling the truth.
Why would they tell the truth if
it was just a weather balloon?
What they really put on this fucking
dog and pony show where they'd have a,
a general sit there and,
or was it colonel,
whoever it was on his knees pointing
out all the retro look a list.
He is just record.
Right,
right.
Well,
that's what colonel courses said.
That's,
you know,
he was,
there's no question that this
was something very legitimate.
And,
and,
uh,
in fact,
you know,
when Barry Goldwater,
senator Goldwater had McCain seat,
um,
before John Mccain took it in Arizona.
I was at his home some years ago and
he had left the Senate and he told me,
he said,
look,
he says it was a God damn mistake.
Then it was like God damn mistake
now that this was ever kept secret,
but he was an air force reserve general.
And he told me that
Senator Goldwater said,
look,
I asked Curtis Lemay,
General Lemay to get me into the
blue room at Wright Patterson,
uh,
because I wanted to see this stuff was
he had heard reports from other pilots
about Ufo encounters and senator,
uh,
go,
go order a told me that courtesy may said,
look,
Barry,
I can't even get into that area anymore.
And if you ever ask me about this again,
I will personally see that you were
court marshaled out of the air force,
reserves this to a city sitting senator
and a guy who had run for president of
course in 1964 and it actually happened.
Yeah,
no,
that's,
you know,
amazing,
amazing stories.
Well,
I was sitting there with the senator
and I have a guy who was there with me.
And you know what I,
when I asked him was,
was Curtis Lemay serious?
He said,
yeah,
like a heart attack.
He says,
I never brought it up again.
And so the question becomes,
you know,
when you have someone like Curtis Lemay
who admits and if you'll Google who he
was,
who admits to the fact that at a
certain point even he was being kind of
sidelined in terms of access of it,
this information and then threatens and
said something like that to a sitting
powerful US
senator did.
They were good friends.
I mean,
they were buddies.
Um,
you know,
there,
there's,
there's something going on here and I've
heard too many accounts like that from
these sorts of people.
And,
uh,
I think it's a,
it's a time for people to understand that,
you know,
ruthless people are out there
and they do this sort of stuff.
So,
you know,
when,
uh,
what happened for the last 60 years
continues to go on and on and on.
You,
you,
the,
the people who try to move into this,
who were politicians and the,
the same boasts all the
senator Goldwater did
these incredibly powerful technologically
advanced beings that come here from
another planet and are concerned with the
fact that we've developed the power to
blow ourselves up,
but yet lack the understanding,
the intellect or the,
the,
the spiritual capacity to recognize what
the dangers and the repercussions of
those actions would be.
What,
what are they,
are they,
is anybody communicating with them?
Does anybody have a message from them?
Does,
is there anything that they say,
we'll be done if we keep fucking around?
I mean,
is there,
uh,
is,
is there like
any,
any doctrine that they're
trying to push on us?
Oh,
I don't know if there's any doctor,
and I think they're
waiting for us to reach,
you know,
uh,
you mentioned this physicist Mitch got,
you know,
a level one civilization or a level to
where we began to behave in a halfway
civilized way so that we could
be quite open and our contact.
But I think,
you know,
I think everyone always says,
well,
why don't they just land on the
White House lawn or so I said,
yeah,
right,
who's White House?
Right?
Humans who says we rule it's American,
right?
Yeah.
So,
um,
maybe the White House in Bogota,
Colombia,
I think the question is,
is,
uh,
it turns,
it,
it the,
the whole issue upside down.
What do we have to do as a
people and the civilization to,
uh,
be able to go into space and have open
contact with these civilizations quite an
in an overt way as
opposed to episodic way.
And I think that requires us to begin,
begin to behave peacefully.
It certainly requires that we not begin
to weaponize space and that we stopped
doing things that are
incredibly self destructive.
Um,
but I,
you know,
the idea that they're
going to land here in,
in four,
it's like us going to Afghanistan think
we're going to impose Jeffersonian
democracy on a medieval feudal society.
Really,
that never has worked.
So I think these civilizations are smart
enough to know that that isn't the way
this is going to happen.
The humans.
But the,
the problem is that I kind of think we're
running out of time to get some things
right.
Things that should have been
fixed a hundred years ago,
like w living together peacefully,
bringing out these technologies
that we don't destroy the biosphere,
eliminating poverty in the world.
You know,
48% of the,
the,
the public doesn't have a pot to pee in.
Literally,
they don't have indoor
plumbing on this planet.
40% of the 7 billion
people that people don't know that.
So,
you know,
I think that until we began to
fix some of these larger problems,
and the good news about all of this
is that it's fixable and the means the
technologies to do that or
are already in existence.
So if they're already in existence
and the science has been studied in
suppressed and studied in
suppressed for decades,
it,
it means that we as a people
have to come together and say,
all right,
we're going to do this.
And,
and the,
I think this is why the,
the,
the sort of hate to use
the word activist advocacy,
part of what we're doing is that people
are always expecting someone else to do
this,
you know?
Um,
and I think people have to say no,
each of us have to be responsible for
the planet and for our future and kind of
creating a good future.
You can't look to big brother to do it.
And I don't think you should look to the
ets to do it and not that they're not
going to help us if we,
at some point we reached a point of,
of heavily into functional.
It's opposed to dysfunctional.
But I,
I think the prime movers
have to be the people.
We,
the people and you know,
my mom's family were,
were some of the original people in the
American revolution with that terrible
to say we were in the front of the
first prisoner of war with the British.
But,
um,
but I think about the fact that,
you know,
here you had this ragtag bunch of people
in the American revolution taking on
the most powerful navy,
most powerful empire in the world at time,
the British empire.
Um,
I think people have to,
to see that within the human spirit
we have the means to do this.
And a lot of people give too much power
to where I don't think it should be
provided,
um,
to these covert groups and
these sort of co cartels.
I think,
again,
I'm getting back to this
idea of empowerment where
we have exactly the power
we're willing to manifest and no more.
But if we're going to sit on our hands
and expect someone else to do it,
we're in trouble.
And there's been too much of that.
And,
and there's,
there needs to be,
um,
I guess a moral courage here.
And I,
I,
you know,
this is what sickened me about,
the politics of the media
and then all these scandals,
you're like,
you were talking about the
with betray us and you know,
during the Clinton era of
the Monica Lewinsky thing,
I call it the,
the blowjob heard round the world.
Um,
that it's just so much nonsense.
Uh,
whereas these big issues or
the moral issues as I see it,
you know,
I think if you look at us as a being
as an entity and our progress in this,
uh,
on this planet,
it's so staggering over such a short
period of time that I think our minds,
our ability to pass down information,
all of these things lag behind.
We're,
we're essentially waking up
in the middle of history as a,
as a,
as a race of beings,
humans,
we're waking up in the middle
of a massive amount of momentum.
As you're born,
you are born into a race that is moving
in an incredibly powerful direction that
it's very hard to stop.
And it's also the same animal that just
twenty thousand thirty thousand go back
as far as you want,
where we were essentially
tribal monkey people,
right?
I mean that's,
that's all of those instincts that allowed
us to get to 2013 are all encoded in
our genome.
All of those instincts,
all of those reward systems are all
encoded and all of those words reward
systems.
Whether you look back to Napoleon or
Kingus Khan or you look at any war figure,
any dominator in throughout human history,
the people in power have always tried to
keep in power and suppress others what
they do and they do.
And,
but I think also if you look at the power
of technology to overwhelm everything,
including the head spook of the CIA,
I mean he was essentially
overwhelmed by email.
That's what took him over.
You know?
I mean it was,
it was the FBI looking into things,
but essentially it was all
done through electronic means.
It was all done through.
He was revealed by the very powers
that the CIA uses in the first place.
They're spies and the
national security agency.
You can bet on top spy was spied on.
It's in my opinion,
when I look at human history and I look
at where you just try to extrapolate,
when I try to extrapolate
where we're going,
it seems to me that it's all symbiotically
connected to technology and that
seems unavoidable.
That's why I have such a hard time with
the idea of someone creating some zero
point energy thing.
That's not,
that people don't,
aren't looking into enough people
know about what Tesla was working on.
Enough people are fascinated by the
ideas of wormholes and I just would think
that more people would be involved in
this and that the government with all it's
shady,
nefarious arms wouldn't be able
to put out all of those fires.
But a lot of it,
if it's
self censoring,
for example,
I'll give you a really good example.
There was an academic guy that uh,
uh,
I was talking to recently and he was
wanting to push into this issue and
basically he was told,
no,
you're not going to do it this university
because this is violating the second
law of thermodynamics and blah,
blah,
blah.
You know,
in a rational world,
which is what you're talking about,
I would agree with you.
But we don't live in a rational world.
We live in a world where there are a lot
of emotions and power hierarchies and
all kinds of dysfunctions.
And so you have to factor
that into the equation.
And I don't think you can underestimate
the reach of the national security
state,
not just here,
but around the world to,
uh,
put out these fires,
no matter how many times
they try to surface,
unless it's done in a very large way.
And I,
and I didn't believe that.
Uh,
and I've learned the hard way trying
to do it in a smaller fashion from this
sunlight.
The story I told you about this,
the scientist who works in a
skiff down near the Huntsville,
spaceflight center,
um,
Marshall space flight
center in Huntsville.
And,
and I think what we are going to have
to do is organize an effort that is very
much outside of government and mainstream
corporations and even academia because
academia,
if you have never been in it,
is so political.
I mean,
uh,
you know,
the,
you touch the sorts of issues
and it's the end of your career.
I'll,
I'll give you a great story in
terms of other institutions.
You know,
the National Science Foundation is a
very big player in global warming studies
and all this kind of stuff.
And the deputy director of that and then
Dr Bob Correll and I had a long meeting
with,
with another person who was one of the
five directors of NASA back some years
ago.
And I,
and you know,
he was very interested in
exactly what we're talking about,
these sciences and studies.
And I said,
look,
we need some people at the
National Science Foundation,
uh,
to,
to really take this on as an
area of research and development,
funding,
et cetera.
He says,
it'd be the end of my
career if I did this.
I said,
well,
you know,
here is the future of
the earth or your career.
What are you going to choose?
Let's choose the earth and our future.
But the truth is everyone puts
their pants on one leg at a time.
And a lot of folks are not going to
jeopardize their careers and their income.
A very famous astronomer
who worked with Carl Sagan,
um,
uh,
was,
at our meetings in 1997
that we did for Congress.
And after he did that with us,
he was told if he ever
wanted to be published again,
right again or have a career in astronomy,
he'd have to leave this issue alone.
So he was directly threatened
and he begged me to,
to,
you know,
keep going forward,
but that he couldn't be part of it.
And so I think that,
you know,
most people don't realize
that this happens every day
and it's kind of a miracle
that this,
this many military and
corporate intelligence people
came together this far.
But I won't even begin to tell you what
we've gone through trying to get this
far.
It's been very difficult.
And,
and so for every person you hear about
it and that you see in this film serious
or,
or in the disclosure project,
there are a hundred that wouldn't be
that I have given me the information and
even documents in intelligence,
but they don't want to
come out and be identified.
So there's a lot of fear of,
of either reprisals but also
just the ridicule factor.
You know,
I have a document from 1953 from the
CIA that talked about engaging Disney
studios to make of cartoonish movies
about this issue so that it would be the
butt of jokes.
And,
and,
and this document talks
about the psychological
warfare value of the subject.
So,
you know,
people are sort of like,
in middle school where you're worried
about what are people gonna think about me
if I say,
I think this is real,
are you going to lose credibility if
you're a doctor or a physicist or an
engineer or a politician?
Project Blue Book wasn't
that this predated this,
this,
this actually predated that when they
were first coming together with how do we
manage this because it's
hidden in plain sight.
People are going to see these objects.
Um,
there's no way to really sanitize it.
You know,
people think you can
really get rid of this.
Well,
you can,
if there's certain number of
people seeing this all the time,
we were highly credible.
So,
but if you create an environment where
it's ridiculous and you're considered a
kook or this or that,
uh,
if you are identified
with it or you'll be,
you know,
governor Moonbeam or senator,
a space cadet or something.
Um,
and this is one of the real problems is
that the subject has been so ridiculed
and there's so much ridiculous stuff
out there on the subject that's provably
nonsensical,
um,
that credible people really
have to swallow hard.
I have to tell you,
the scientists that are at this Major
Ivy League university doing the work on
this little body,
this humanoid type body,
um,
you know,
big,
big thing for them to be working on this.
Um,
and it's even a bigger thing that they're
going to go on the record about their
findings.
When are they going to
do this in the next,
well,
you'll see on April 22nd
comes to the premiere.
I'll come to the premiere,
but on April 22nd what if no
one has made some sort of a,
a public statement?
No.
Ivy League scientists,
they're going to,
so yes,
you're promising between
now and April 22nd,
there'll be some sort of a reveal.
We'll,
we'll have some,
these releases,
major institution scientists of credible
history will step forward and say,
hey,
this is,
this is something we don't
know what they're going to say.
They're still doing the run on the genome.
Well,
he's extraordinary.
If it's real,
if it's,
it's a,
if it is,
okay,
let me put that to rest right now.
You touched it.
Yeah,
I've touched it.
We have the cat scans.
We have the reports from
these top scientists.
The only thing left that we're
doing is running the genome,
which is the whole genome.
So that scientists have said that it's
absolutely a biological origin that is
not,
it's not like my werewolf.
No,
no.
Robert,
this,
we know this,
we absolutely know and put that to rest.
Has this damaged your credibility in life?
I mean,
have you,
have you suffered because
of this in any way,
shape or form?
Of course.
In what way?
Every way.
Yeah.
It's been the hardest thing.
You know,
I tell people the worst days
in the Er or you know how old,
a three year old that died in my arms.
This has been harder.
So,
you know,
it's harder than a death of a little baby.
Really.
Yeah.
The stuff we've had to deal with,
like in what way?
Horrible stuff I don't
really won't go into,
I mean,
we probably don't have time,
but,
um,
every nasty thing that can be done
has been done or attempted to be done.
Too many of us and particularly to to us,
uh,
my,
my family and
my family so much is,
is,
you know,
targeting me with
nastiness of it was just unbelievable
and ridicule and always know that.
Yeah.
People threaten you to what?
Stop talking about Ufos.
Um,
you know,
problems that we've had with them.
A lot of security problems.
I mean there was an FBI file over open
on this because of the death threats and
this stuff we've had.
And so you,
these death threats are from these people
that you're exposing that are in the
cabal of this.
Who knows where coming from.
You could
just say it with some nut job,
like the people who shot up the,
the Sikh temple,
where are our directors
family as you know,
his father was murdered
horribly at this thing.
And uh,
but you know,
I'm just saying that it's a lot easier
being an emergency doctor than dealing
with this issue when you know it's real
and you're dealing with this level of
intelligence in the CIA
has affected your career.
Yeah,
I've left medicine not cause I had to,
no,
I mean,
but because I had to
choose how I put this.
You only have 24 hours in a day.
And you know,
at a certain point I had to decide I'm
either going to continue as a physician
or I'm going to go full steam on this.
Now of course it was a big sacrifice for
my family and I was given up hundreds
of thousands of dollars a year as
a doctor to do this for nothing.
All right.
So,
um,
it's been difficult.
So I just,
what I'm saying,
it's been difficult in every way,
but that,
that's not important.
I'm not sure.
Well,
it is important and you're,
you,
that's a,
it's a tremendous sacrifice.
Um,
especially cause it's something
that you would truly believe in.
How do you support yourself now?
Well,
um,
I have enough resourcefulness.
I,
before I left medicine,
I bought my home and I'd saved enough
and invest enough that I'm okay.
Um,
and then I have a little bit of income
from some of the books and things,
but I mean,
it's very modest compared to,
you know,
what I would have been making.
I,
you know,
I'd probably in the aggregate of,
given up around somewhere
in the neighborhood of five
to $6 million in income
doing this,
um,
w which I actually don't regret at all
because I don't care about the money.
Um,
I,
I care about people say that
I hate when people say that.
No,
I really don't.
I mean,
this is why,
you know,
and now this the deal probably
string credulity here,
but a former head of army intelligence
approached me in 1992 and,
uh,
offered me,
um,
the kind of control
over a $2 billion fund.
If I would shut up and close down
the disclosure project and see Seti,
uh,
could not control over a
$2 billion fund with a,
B,
two g.
And what,
what did he want you to do?
Just basically,
I could do anything with it.
So long as I of shut,
you could just go big
pimpin giant yacht Ferrari,
who knows.
No,
no more Dr. Greer
and then,
you know,
and I said,
no,
I'm not going to do that because I really
believe that this issue needs to be
dealt with it properly.
The Guy who went to my wife and
tried to convince her to convince me,
and this,
you know,
this is the kind of thing,
does he want you to work for him or
he just wanted you to share them?
He wanted me to merge what we were
doing with some operation he had,
which would have
basically subsumed it and,
and cooperative and,
and I said,
no.
And then he made another
run and I said no.
And then about a month after that,
all over the Internet,
it came out that I wasn't even a doctor.
Here I am in this emergency department
and it's a bunch of goons and put out
there that I'm not even an
actual MD and I'm there,
you know,
up to my eyeballs in blood and guts
and in the Er and this thing breaks.
So,
you know,
they do all kinds of disinformation in
psychological warfare stuff on people.
Um,
but I don't really mind
that that's happened.
Uh,
what I'm more concerned about is the
people who have the knowledge and
responsibility,
who don't do the right thing because
there's no way that I can do this by
myself.
And what I was really gratified to see,
and I'm still gratified to see is,
you know,
are all these people,
the military men and women and others who
have come forward a very courageously,
um,
academics like the ones doing the
work on this potential little humanoid
creature,
which is a real creature,
whether it,
what it is,
we don't know,
but they,
it's a really courageous thing
for these people to be doing that.
Um,
the people who led the charge and
France to release all these documents.
Um,
I know the backstory to that,
that the public doesn't know.
Um,
and there were,
it was very controversial.
So I mean,
this is the kind of courage we need,
uh,
to get the truth out and to
go forward as a civilization.
And,
um,
so,
you know,
you can't buy it.
You got to have it.
You got to manifest it.
Him.
Are you getting income from this?
Hm.
No.
You don't get any income from them?
This is um,
you know,
and you know what's
beautiful about serious it,
the movie is that it was all crowdfunded.
No,
no one on my team has
taken any funds from,
it's all going into the
production of the movie.
You don't even take a salary?
No.
Oh No,
no.
It's all gone into,
into the film.
But you list expenses like
I don't you list like a,
the several hundred,
$270,000 or something and expenses
that you charge to create this,
uh,
this film.
Well,
yeah,
that's the production company.
You know,
cause I'm not a filmmaker,
right.
Don't ask me to turn on campus.
So we have people to
this production company
and then of course we're going to,
uh,
you know,
he had to organize the premiere
and of course being crowd funded,
you have to fulfill all the
incentives for the crowd funding.
I don't know if you know crowd funding,
but I want to thank everyone
who's listening by the way.
We did a Kickstarter and then our
own private program and you know,
we have like 4,000 people who
have contributed funds to this,
which is really a huge number of folks.
And um,
and by the way,
all of you folks who've done that,
the uh,
I just want to,
can I say this to the premier is going
to be here in Los Angeles on Earth Day,
April 22nd at the,
um,
uh,
la live,
the Ricoh la live,
uh,
cinemas downtown,
the premier theater.
And um,
so that's April 22nd.
If you want to come,
you can kind of sign up and get
tickets at serious disclosure,
calm.
I'm writing that in my calendar right now.
I'm going to try to make that,
that sounds really fascinating.
I can't tweet us.
And you're invited to come,
come as my guest.
Love
to have you as my guest.
If you want.
I would love to go.
We're going to have a red carpet and
we're going to invite some other,
um,
you know,
people here in Hollywood
and in the business and um,
it's going to be an exciting event.
I mean the theater only holds 809 people
of which about half of those seats are
already spoken for.
But um,
but you know,
those of you want to come,
you
know,
just hop online and you know,
the system is set up so you
can do it all digitally.
You know,
it's not going to be
tickets at the door though.
Okay.
Um,
what is this thing that you're doing
where you leave people out into the desert
and you have them make contact with
something if Uriel crafts and beings and
what,
what is that?
Well,
that's the whole [inaudible] concept.
I was talking about close encounters of
the fifth kind that we're using these
different protocols.
And by the way,
there's a,
there's a smartphone,
an iPhone app for this that you
can get it serious disclosure.com.
So that has all the,
it'll actually turn your phone
into a magnet magnetometer.
It has the tones that were recorded in
this crop circle of this weird energy
that came into the crops
on my phone right now.
Yes.
You can get them what it called.
It's called the contact app,
I'll and it,
and it's at,
it's at a,
you can go to serious
disclosure.com and there's a,
uh,
an icon there and you can link and it
goes to the either the iTunes store or the
android store.
Okay.
And,
um,
what happens when you take these feed,
you'll take anyone out there.
Did they have to go through
a screening process?
Like there's an APP.
I mean it's of course it's a,
if we do about a week training of people
in remote viewing and the protocols of
contact and uh,
they're sort of the whole concept of it,
but also how to look at the night sky.
You go out with satellite charts.
We have fourth generation night scopes.
We have really good cameras.
Um,
and you know,
in fact we're going to be
doing one in Colorado in June.
I'm in the high desert.
I have some land up there.
Um,
what is the actual name of this app?
Because there was a
couple of contact apps.
Well again,
you have to go to serious disclosure.com
and there's a link there for it.
I,
you know the name of the
name of your own app.
You know,
I have so many irons in the fire.
I think it's called a the t contact at
o t contact that I'm gonna try that t
contract up.
So,
and explain to me what,
what happens here.
You have a course and in this
course what are these people do?
The idea is,
is that we want to see your signal.
That is,
that is.
So I just bought your APP.
Powerful.
Okay.
So explain to me where would someone
sign up for something like this?
Yeah.
And we do these expeditions
a few times a year.
Um,
I used to,
there there are only
about 20 people who are,
who are allowed to come now,
um,
when you had a time,
cause I can't handle more than that for
a week out in the desert or out in the
mountains,
but um,
and I just don't have time to do it
more often than the four or five times a
year that we do.
So you do it quarterly you,
um,
well yeah,
the seasonally,
but the schedule is
up@cirrusdisclosure.com.
There's a place where do
you bring these people?
It just depends.
I mean like we're at,
the next one is going to be in
the high desert of Colorado.
I'm at about 8,000 feet.
It was a remote area near the great sand
dunes that's had a lot of reports of
Ufos and contact.
In fact,
uh,
the film director and his crew were
out there last a few months ago
in 2012 when we had this disc fly over
and then a jet came into intercepted and
just,
and that's going to be in the film.
It's really cool video of that
or a photo that both really,
so you have a video of this disk in
the sky and then a jet approaching a
discount probably coming
out of Colorado Springs.
So that was coming out of that direction.
But yeah,
it was,
it's,
it's really pretty cool.
And of course,
I think when,
when the director saw this,
he went,
oh wow.
And who put this video together?
Who made it?
Who filmed it?
Uh,
the film crew for serious.
So you,
uh,
wow.
So we have,
want to make sure we'll clear this.
You have thousands of these
videos where there's one,
uh,
yeah.
If you go again to this website,
you'll see that there's a section for the,
where the contact expeditions in the c
five expeditions and a couple of years
ago we were up on,
now there's a mountain
north of here called Mt.
Shasta near the Oregon border,
um,
in the cascade range.
And it's a volcanic mountain.
And we've gone up there a number of years
and we've had these objects that have
appeared and one of them
was actually in the field.
Um,
we had their night vision camera
running and it lifted up and does this.
And then this,
like this corkscrew in d
materialize in the sky.
We have this on video tape and it was
during one of these expeditions and it's a
really amazing,
um,
bit of video.
Is Ball lightening a real phenomenon?
Uh,
Oh yeah,
sure,
sure.
And that,
that's not it.
This is clear skies,
no weather coming up from the
ground but don't they but,
but doesn't ball lightning
to have something to do with,
uh,
there's,
there's certain types of,
of visual phenomenon that have to do
with tectonic plates and pressure and
stress.
Pizo Electric.
Yeah.
What do you know what that's very
different also that be just sort of a
discharge,
like an electrical discharge
and that's from the rocks.
And usually it's when there's quartz
depressure of it into an electromagnetic
energy will build up in Oberst burst out.
But you know,
this is an object and you can
see it quite clearly and it's,
uh,
it's right at the edge of the speed of
light cause it's kind of coming in and
out of this dimension.
It's a really great video
and there were like 30,
40 people who saw this happen.
Um,
so we do this.
I've been doing this for 22 years.
And um,
uh,
what would he,
what are you showing up there Brian?
What is,
uh,
it was one of these
objects that came over.
I think that was at Mount Shasta.
I'm not sure.
It's my laser and it was this
object that came right over.
And you know,
we also train people who always
go out with satellite charts.
No,
w you know,
so you know when the satellite footage
of this thing flying in the sky.
Yup.
Whoa.
And if that's your laser,
that's my,
I have a big,
you know,
it's one of these,
I got one of those.
Yeah,
it'll go away.
It'll go a hundred,
200 miles in the space.
Um,
to,
uh,
now when you,
when you were filming this,
are you trying to contact them?
Like what are you trying,
we had,
so we do the protocols where
you do the remote viewing,
set up the vector,
show them where you are.
We played these electronic
tones in the space.
And then have electronic
field detectors out there.
So we'll have magnetic field detectors,
various lasers detectors,
other electromagnetic spectrum.
And those will begin to go.
And then we'll have an object fly over
like this object here that was right near
as it comes right outside.
So what people have to understand is
that if you have an object that is coming
in and out of dimensions,
it's not going to necessarily look like
a seven 47 or even a flying saucer.
It's going to be in various energy forms.
And this is the weird sort of effect.
Uh,
most people don't understand that 99%
of the time an interstellar civilization
doesn't have to be in linear space
time if they have that kind of physics.
So what happens when you go beyond the
speed of light or you're going to not
have anything visible,
but if you begin to have
an energy discharge into an
area of space and it's very
close to this dimension,
it'll start to give off
an energy field or corona.
And so one of the witnesses we have was
that a nuclear hot base out in Oklahoma
back a years ago,
I think it was in the 70s.
And there was this object
that was in the shape of Ufo,
but it wasn't solid.
And it flew over the,
what they call the hot,
you know,
with the jets were hot load with
nuclear weapons and the alarms went off.
But he says this thing was not solid.
Like this is,
uh,
like your rock salt.
Um,
it was,
you could have walked right through it,
but it was in the shape of a craft,
but it was shifted so that
the matter was all energy.
And of course matter is energy.
So the physics behind this gets into
some really arcane stuff probably beyond
the scope of the show.
But it's what I,
this is part of what we're teaching people
when we take them out is how do these
objects appear?
What might you see?
And I was talking to a,
an actor here in town who had one of
these happen near his home and it was very
palpable and very real,
but it wasn't,
can you tell us who the actor was?
Because now there are no,
but he,
you know,
the,
these are,
there are a lot of people who've
had these sort of experiences.
They don't want to talk about it because
they're afraid of being ridiculed and,
but you know,
when it was described to me,
I said,
well yeah,
that's classic.
They really,
I said,
yeah,
because if it's,
if it's not a lucky Martin,
you know,
antigravity and it's really as CT,
the weirder it is,
the more likely it is to be Iti.
And this gets into the whole question,
what are you looking for?
So we train people to know kind
of what to look for versus,
you know,
if experimental aircraft,
normal aircraft,
you know,
space objects in junk,
uh,
satellites and then the stuff,
that's
the weird end of it.
So the weird end of it.
Yeah,
they're really cool stuff.
Really cool stuff.
You take these people,
you bring them out to the high desert,
you tune them into whatever frequency
through whatever methods of meditation or,
or what have you.
And these ships are they just waiting
for someone to like email them,
send them a signal?
You know what I think,
I think that they've actually been
waiting a long time for people to do
something.
Just passively look at them.
Did they have to,
but what I'm saying is do they
have to like load up the ship?
Hey,
we got some fucking people in the desert.
Everybody get on board now let's go,
let's go.
Ha.
And then how are you
getting them to manifest?
I'm not getting them to,
but how is anybody getting,
how was it,
how was the signal being
recognized by them?
Because I'm quite convinced they have
electronics that pick up on this,
what we were talking about earlier,
this conscious field of coherent
thought and this is again the most
controversial and of what I'm doing it
to me it's the most interesting also,
um,
you know,
before it was a doctor,
I was a meditation teacher.
I don't know if you know that,
but,
um,
no,
I didn't know that was it.
What type of meditation?
A mantra in vedic Vedanta
and vedic meditation.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
I learned Sanskrit and learn
to teach people meditation.
So that was my first sort of career,
if you can call it a career,
it was an avocation as much
as more than a vocation.
But um,
and I really,
and it was caused as a result
of this near death experience.
And,
and,
and I began to realize
that really the thing that,
that is most intriguing about all this
is that free energy is like late 18
hundreds to mid 19 hundreds
antigravity mid forties to mid fifties.
The science of consciousness and the
interface between mind and matter,
mind and body,
mind and thought in
electromagnetic systems.
That's the really cool stuff.
And that's,
you know,
to me,
most people know me for the disclosure
project and these other things,
but to me that's the most exciting part
of this because that is the frontier.
The final from tier is not
space is consciousness.
So you take these people out,
there's 20 of them and you
spend how many days out there?
Um,
it's,
it's usually six days and nights.
And um,
so we go out during the day,
it's more a teaching module and teaching
them a remote viewing concepts and
science of consciousness.
Um,
other information they need to have.
Then we go out at night,
usually from around sunset to one
or so in the morning sometimes too.
Um,
and we're in out in the
stars making observation,
doing the remote viewing practice
and then people go home and do it.
But there's now something like 11 or
1200 teams all over the world doing this,
that we,
that or have picked up on this idea.
Uh,
it's really a phenomenal thing.
And um,
people are having amazing slidings
and experiences all over the world.
There's a global CE five initiative,
uh,
going on and um,
it's,
it's really exciting.
Ce Five,
which is visual.
No,
what does,
what does it,
okay,
let me explain to you,
I'm sorry,
I don't know the movie,
the third kind of Steven
Spielberg's movie.
That's how I know this.
Most people are probably like me.
They don't pay in the fourth kind is when
someone feels they've had contact and
been on board.
The fifth kind is a term that I,
um,
uh,
launched a and the concept of in 1990,
which is when humans instead of passively
having to all those others close
encounters as the first,
second,
third and fourth kind or passive,
could you saw her either seen it or
it's a landing thing or what have you.
A close encounter of the fifth kind is
when a human does something interactive.
So it's like,
you know,
it's like the Internet versus
something passive or where you're,
you're actually making
contact and inviting the
civilizations to appear and make
contact for diplomatic purpose,
um,
or where they interact.
And Dr. Haynes at Nasa Ames put together,
uh,
a great book,
based on,
on my initial research on this called
close encounters of the fifth time.
I'm CE five,
where he collected cases.
We both collected cases,
but he published this book some years ago,
um,
about,
uh,
all these people who had done this and
some of them were quite incidental.
For example,
a craft is there and the person
sees it and instead of just gaping,
they actually signaled to it with say
a a light and it signals back and comes
over.
The more interesting ones are the ones
I discovered that which is what happened
to me when I was 18 where you see a craft
and you just think moved to the left
and moves to the left,
move to the right,
move to the right.
And they're showing you that there's a
link up between intent and thought and
their electronics.
And that's the really cool stuff.
You remember how many young Carl Young?
Yes.
What did you,
what do you think on co he wrote a whole
book on the physical manifestation of
Ufos through the conscious thought.
Yeah.
Well I mean the world
is as you are and um,
it depends on the level of consciousness
of the person reading what he wrote.
Um,
I think that a lot of people say,
well that means that you're,
everything is being
manifested by your mind.
Well,
but in a sense,
all of reality is one conscious thought.
If you want to look good,
get back into the hole.
All this is that concept of the vedic.
But I think,
uh,
these are things when you
have 30 or 40 people see it
and it's interactive,
you know,
it's a close encounter
with the fifth kind.
So it's not your imagination doing that.
Um,
particularly didn't get video.
I don't actually think he was
necessarily saying it's your imagination.
No,
no.
But he was,
you know,
a lot of people don't understand what
he was saying and I think that he was
taught really talking about some,
a deeper aspect of what his mind,
right.
What is modern mind,
what effect does consciousness
have on physical matter?
Right.
It's huge.
And in a sense he could have almost
been validating it without totally
understanding the possibilities of
contacting something when we're making
something.
I agree.
You,
you seem to be convinced of,
and in fact,
teach people to do it.
I think that if you've
got something like that,
how has this not like on 2020 or
whatever those stupid new shows are,
how will you not going well you'd be
willing to do that with a film crew.
Oh we did with CBS with
Dan Rather had a show,
I'm back a years ago.
What was it called?
Um,
we went down to Mexico and it Popo and
we did this in a craft came up by the,
by the volcano flu and they were filming
this with professional stuff and they
ended up uh,
completely debunking at end
even though the camera guy and,
and the uh,
reporter who was there with me said,
anyone who sees this
will know this is real.
And CBS sanitized it.
And when I then said,
look,
you agreed in writing
that any footage you get,
you would share with us
if we did this expedition.
Cause we did it on our own expense.
They,
the,
the person in charge there said received
bs and we're part of a corporation has
billions and you don't,
you will fight you for,
you'll never get this footage needs CBS
though it seems like you'd be able to
film something like that
yourself and really high quality.
You don't need their footage.
What we do,
I mean we have a certain amount,
I don't operate cameras,
but we,
we've had volunteers but we've never
had professional cruise with us.
And I mean at some point it'd be
nice if we could do this and I'm a
professional,
I have a crew,
I have a new show that's coming
out on the SCIFI network.
Oh really?
What's it's called?
Question everything and good.
One of the things,
yeah,
and one of the things we're going to do
is we're going to explore things like
Ufo was big foot.
I'm going to go to the Pacific
northwest and look for bigfoot,
but I want to,
let's go to the Atacama desert
and see if we can find him.
Let's go,
man.
I would,
I would be more than happy to go and
bring a professional crew and see if,
uh,
something like this can happen.
What kind of success rate
do you have in doing this?
Uh,
well,
you know,
we've never actually gone out where there
hasn't been some kind of a siding or
event happened that had
been seen by everyone.
Really.
Never.
So it's 100%,
not every night and not all the time,
but yes.
Something of five or six day period.
And are these people camping out there?
No,
no,
no.
We don't stay.
Well,
I mean,
I guess if someone wanted to,
we usually stay in condos or houses or
something in the area we usually go to
fairly knows,
you know,
Eh,
remote areas that are a quiet,
it's very hard to find locations where
we're not going to be intruded upon.
And usually when we do this,
um,
we do have people who intrude.
Um,
and,
and so we try to keep it,
you know,
so that the group can be coherent
because the whole concept of,
of this is coherent
thought and coherent mind.
And,
uh,
that's,
you know,
very difficult to do when you're
being disrupted by a lot of folks.
Know what if you pick 20 people to go and,
and,
and how,
how do you know that someone's not alone?
He takes some crackpot.
Oh,
well,
there had been no,
usually the people,
you know,
we have an application process and,
and I,
I,
you know,
I'd say 99% of the time
they're just wonderful people.
And you know,
they're very sincerely interested
in learning about this.
And I think the science of consciousness
component of the whole what JL and
Harnett called the High
Strangeness Part of Ufo Encounters,
um,
is becomes very compelling for people
who have had contact and understand that
when you go beyond the speed
of light between star systems,
you're dealing with,
uh,
something that's way beyond,
your,
your phone and,
and a Ford explorer.
And,
and people who get that,
who get out of the linear box and
begin to look at that and then begin to
experiment with a lot of
the people who come on.
These are people who have gotten
the APP or learned about it.
And they try it at,
try this at home and they have an amazing
citing an encounter with a small group
of people or a family and then they
want to come and try and do it more.
So,
um,
uh,
it,
it's,
it's uh,
an excite to me that's the,
the,
the next phase of all this is,
you know,
disclosure,
bring out the energy and technologies,
but then it's about the
public understanding that,
what does it,
everyone just go out under the stars
instead of sitting and looking at
television and try some experiments,
experiment with,
with thought in mind,
light and tone and all kinds of
interesting things and space.
Haven't you encountered
things that are uh,
in closer proximity to the ground?
Oh yeah.
And have some very odd photographs of
what you might call a trans dimensional
images that looked like a,
almost like a Hologram of a bean that
floated right outside of our circle at
Joshua tree national park.
Not too far from here.
A back a few years ago about Theresa,
this thing.
Yup.
Where can someone see that as
one of the websites series,
disclosure.com.
If you link to the CE five part of it,
there's a whole section of
this strange luminous thing.
Um,
and you know,
a,
the photograph of that.
It was a three or four second exposure.
And what was seen right
before this happened,
which is really important for people to
understand what something about half the
size of the,
about the size of my
fist or a little bigger.
It was like a sphere that
floated over the desert.
Um,
and uh,
November of Oh nine and
several people saw it.
And then we heard what sounded
like a group of people talking,
but with our nights,
cause there's nothing there.
And then,
so a woman on my team took her camera
and it just had a three or four second
exposure,
took a photograph.
And in that area where this had happened,
there was this beam that was,
uh,
and did you see this
with your eyes or is it,
you know,
cause this would have been in a flash,
but it's in the digital.
Is it possible that it's just an artifact?
No,
it's not an artifact.
Absolutely not.
Why is that not possible?
Flashes always produce artifacts.
It produced,
no,
she did not use a flash.
Oh,
it was visible.
The flash was so,
in other words,
this was no flash bulb.
No,
we don't allow flash
photography when we're out.
You've got to have good nights.
Goats,
you have to have good cameras.
You can adjust the ISO and the,
and the aperture and all that.
Um,
campfires.
Hmm.
No,
we never have camp fires.
There's a complete darkness.
Um,
the most you're going to see when
we're out there has made me an led on a
camera.
So whatever this thing was,
we know what it was.
You think it was very
confident about what it was.
Have you ever been a board,
a spatial and a well,
you know,
um,
I've had some really amazing contact
experiences that are classic and they,
you know,
uh,
I had one when I was,
having,
uh,
this eight when I was 18 years
old up on this mountain up in,
uh,
and,
and it,
it was,
it wasn't at all what you hear about in
the literature because it was more in
this trans dimensional element,
uh,
area.
And that becomes the whole question is
what part of what people are reporting is
real and what part is memorex.
And this is something we
haven't talked about yet,
but what is the capacity for the
intelligence community to hoax contact?
And it's substantial.
Really?
Yeah.
You think a lot of people they,
they're hoaxing contact
yeah.
For scaring the hell out of people.
Like in what way?
How do they do that?
Uh,
one of the things we learned about a
number of years ago is actually not
something I discovered.
It was a man here who was looking into um,
what are called military related
abductions that are made to look at ut but
aren't.
And you get into this whole question of
what are they able to stage craft two
for four,
it's psychological warfare value.
And I have a document that's actually
gonna be in the film and it's from the
strategic studies institute talking
about the staging of abductions and other
scary things to create
fear around the UFO issue.
So they create an artificial
spacecraft and abducting.
Yeah.
Well they might use,
they may use what's called an arb,
an alien reproduction
vehicle that's manmade.
They may use robotic
things that are called pls,
program life forms that are
manmade but look very easy
lifeforms,
yeah,
pls,
they have,
they have lifeforms that,
that are like robots essentially
that move around like people.
Uh,
there are reports of that
and in fact a ports of that.
And I think there is,
if you leave it though,
oh yeah.
I think Stan Rome and neck,
if you look at the photograph he had of,
uh,
this thing,
I think he was on Larry King or
in some other shows in this thing,
bu that goes up and down.
He's got a photo and then
there's a video that,
uh,
he hasn't released,
but I've seen it in other
people in the team have seen it.
And it's this very robotic looking.
It looks like a quote alien,
but we know it isn't.
I mean,
so I,
you know,
the question is why would they
want to do something like that?
I think if you can put enough
information out there to scale,
scare people,
why not
scare all,
it seems to me though that look at the
highest level robotics experts in the
world today are pretty open about
their work because they're there.
But these are showing,
I mean they're,
they're,
they're showing periodic improvements.
The general public like that Darpa robots,
what they're doing in Japan.
No,
no one has come anywhere close to
doing something along those lines.
Not only that,
they all have an external power source.
Yeah.
But you're assuming that the things
that you know about her or all that,
they're an existence,
but it's like saying that,
uh,
because you haven't flown on a one to
lock heats or Northrop's antigravity
devices.
They don't have those either.
I think that yes,
they do.
Absolutely.
100% yes.
How has it been rich all but said,
so you know,
who's the head of Lockheed Skunk works?
Um,
so these are a lot of the things that
people will see out near the Nellis
Ranger,
so called area 51 that are,
are moving in decent ways.
We were talking about earlier,
those are manmade.
There's aren't AET.
And if you go all way back to,
uh,
the forties in,
in Germany,
during World War II and after they were
doing a lot of experiments with things
that do electromagnetic lifter effect.
And going back a little further,
you look at t Townsend Brown in 19,
late 1920s,
uh,
and then also the Closky frost experiment
where they actually were able to
create this effect of
Levitation and movement.
So,
you know,
again,
there's a whole science here.
And in the open aerospace
literature in the late forties,
early fifties,
they were saying the next big thing is
gravity control an antigravity stuff and
Dah,
Dah.
And then it went all white and black.
You can't find it.
And,
uh,
one of the guys that I've worked
with at the naval research labs,
which is the largest
department defense lab,
um,
told me that it was October 54 when we
really mastered gravity control and all
those projects went black.
They just disappeared.
But up until then you
can go back and fine.
And there were,
uh,
in the literature,
now the fact that your average person at
MIT to know about this doesn't mean it
didn't exist.
And I think that there's a whole history
of aerospace and technology that's
hidden.
Similarly,
there's a whole history of robotics,
genetics,
biological studies and what have you.
And that that has also
been very classified.
You are either one really nutty dude or
you are a guy who has tapped into one of
the craziest pieces of information
that's being suppressed from the American
public.
And there's no room for a middle ground.
You know,
I'm,
I know that all,
every word I'm telling you is true.
I believe,
man Wu believe that every word
out of your mouth is true.
I do believe you.
But this whole thing
is so it's so strains,
credibility,
all it does,
all of it does.
And you know what I was told years ago
that if you really told the whole truth
about this,
that'll hide itself cause
no one can believe it.
So you know,
it is kind of through the looking
glass and down the rabbit hole on this
subject.
And it's a real problem because how far
do you go in terms of telling what you
know and have discovered?
Well,
it seems to me
and Hampton to like a way to show people.
Yeah,
well I mean if,
but who's looking at me?
It's like the CFA guy,
John Callahan who said,
I've got the radar tapes,
I got the pilot reports,
but who's looking and who's asking?
Right.
Well not 20,
20.
You know what I mean?
You asked about 2020.
Uh,
the guy was executive producer
of that came out to my house.
I gave him 35 hours at digital
stuff of all these top secret guys,
all the documents,
all this stuff.
He said,
this is the biggest story.
It's either all a hoax or it's
the biggest story in history.
I said,
yeah,
well I think it's the latter.
And he says,
I want to do this story.
I said,
I don't think they'll let you.
And so we went back to corporate ABC and
a couple of weeks later he's a Dr. Greer.
They won't let me do this story.
I said,
who are they,
IRA?
And he said,
well,
you know who they are.
And I've had producers.
They're like,
that's crazy motherfucker.
What else?
This was the executive
producer in charge of the show.
Both the primetime live in 2020 and um,
he's now with the 60 minutes.
But I think that what
we'll love to talk to him.
What's his name?
Yeah,
Ira Rosen.
I love to talk to him on the question.
Everything show.
That'd be fascinating.
Well,
you know,
I think that the,
the,
this is the other big myth is that when
you start dealing with the big media
that it's a free media.
It's free to a point.
I mean,
it's no problem if you want to
drill down on someone's sex scandal.
But if you really want
to deal with this issue,
there's going to be a phone call and you,
one of the documents,
it's a up on our website,
I wrote an article called a media play.
And in it is a document I got from the
1990s from the CIA that talks about how
the CIA had embedded in all the
major media people to change,
alter or,
or stop stories.
And this is an official document.
So you know,
if the public listening out there think
we really have a free market and free
media,
you know,
wake up and this is simply not the case.
So I think that one of the,
one of the challenges
we've had is that the,
the,
it's kind of a,
an article of faith that
if all this were true,
wouldn't immediate just
really want to cover this.
And I say,
yeah,
there were some really good people
in the media who've wanted to,
but they're not allowed to.
And so,
and then this good way,
who controls the big media?
I'm not talking about your show because
I'm talking to how many shows are out
there dedicated to
looking for Ufo was there,
seems like there's quite a bit and
they'll see those shows are owned by,
you know,
big media companies and networks that,
that promote these shows.
It's just bullshit.
And what they're doing is paying lip
service to it and not really looking and
they're just covering the controversial
aspects of it to get viewers.
Yes.
I think a lot of it's shocking.
Dribble in Britain circus.
And I think that you
didn't ask the question of,
you know,
years ago when I was on Larry King and
the afterwards I got this note from his
produce said,
you know,
this is one of the most
popular shows we've ever had.
And so if it was just about ratings and
just about whether there was anything
legitimate there to cover,
this would be in the news all the time.
So there's something weird going on
here because they'll cover all kinds of
sensationalistic nonsense.
But you know,
you have dozens of top secret witnesses,
you have legitimate government documents,
you have photographs,
video,
or you have teams like ours going
out having these sorts of
experiences that isn't covered.
You have to ask the question why.
And I think the wonderful thing about
2013 that didn't exist five or 10 years
ago,
Twitter,
Facebook,
video on demand,
you know,
you don't have to go to a big distributor.
We're,
and actually,
by the way,
we're planning to distribute this
film at the night of the premiere.
Maybe we'll live stream and if
we can figure out how to do it,
maybe you can help us.
Um,
I'll be happy to,
um,
we need help with it actually
because we're actually out of funds.
Well Production Brad Ustream
livestream to show this,
but yeah.
Yeah.
And so what we want to do at the premiers
live stream it and then have the thing
and then it'll be VOD video
on demand so that you know,
there are no choke holds in the big media
and then you couldn't have done that
five or 10 years ago
with any kind of value.
Now you can do high definition,
you can do really good,
good video on demand and we're going to
do this so that everyone can sign up to
be an affiliate distributor.
So that basically if you
want to distribute to show,
you can,
you can distribute it and
the people who see it,
you know,
there'll be a small fee to see it and
then you'll have part of that and you just
build that out.
Because what we want to do is make this
thing go viral so that we don't get into
the choke holds of the big media because,
um,
you know,
I,
uh,
my experience with it is that I'm,
I'm very,
very skeptical of the big media doing
anything with this until they have to.
Um,
and,
and then it becomes where is,
there's too much noise out there.
We have to give it a little bit of lip
service and then we'll take it off again.
So that's why,
by the way,
that's why we did this
crowdfunding to this.
It was that we really wanted the people
to have a stake in it and to move,
move the film serious forward.
Because if you went to a
studio or a group of investors,
you don't know what they're going to
do with it if they control it this way,
the people on it.
So,
well,
listen,
man,
this is a fascinating subject.
Uh,
like I said,
it's one of my personal interest and
it has been since I was a small child,
uh,
and a to talk to you,
it was a real treat.
I really appreciate it
and we really appreciate,
put your neck out there,
man.
You say a lot of nutty shit and it takes
a lot of courage to do that or you're
crazy.
I'm willing to believe you.
I mean,
I'm willing to,
uh,
be completely open to the point of I'll,
I'll go out to the desert with you.
I'll do whatever it is.
I'm,
you know,
I'm fascinated by all this stuff and,
uh,
if what you're saying is true,
it is a,
you know,
one of the most mind blowing things
our society is ever had access to.
It has ever been able to encounter.
I mean it's,
uh,
it's pretty crazy shit man.
Come to the new millennium.
Cause now it's time.
Know,
even,
here we go.
I hope you're right.
I mean,
I hope this isn't just crazy talk.
Um,
April 22nd is the day it's in Los Angeles,
uh,
at La live,
which is where
it's the regal la live,
the Regal Elliot La live.
And how can people,
uh,
either find out about this or get to
this or I want to go serious disclosure,
doc,
uh,
calm.
And you can go there and you can,
you know,
get the tickets and everything
is sign up right there.
Everything would be done online.
And it is the film done.
It's uh,
it's going into final completion
in the next three weeks or so.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
uh,
April 22nd is when it's all going down
and that is hopefully you will already
have the information from this Ivy League
institute about this alien being by
then.
Correct.
Or this humanoid beings human.
We don't know what it is.
Whatever it is.
Yeah.
And we will,
we already have a lot of it,
but we're waiting for the,
the final,
the genetic sequencing.
Okay.
And if people want to
follow you on Twitter,
it's Dr. Steven Greer.
Stevie,
Not one of those Weirdos that says Steven,
but it's with a Ph.
Who does that somewhere?
Knows no ph here.
Yeah,
a lot of Weirdos.
Steven Ph.
That's Stephan.
Right.
Okay.
A doctor,
Steven,
you're s t.
E.
V.
N.
Greer.
And one more time.
The website is serious disclosure,
not come sir.
I U Ius,
disclosure.com.
This has been a fascinating conversation.
Thank you very much.
It's been really interesting and,
uh,
you know,
I mean,
I'm really looking forward
to seeing where this goes.
We'll see you at the premiere.
Absolutely.
Will you do this again?
Will you come by?
Yeah,
yeah.
Around the time of the premiere
with all the new findings.
Yes,
please.
All right.
We're going to have some fun.
Listen folks,
thanks for tuning in.
Uh,
we have a crazy week this week.
We have Thompson euro is
going to be on on Tuesday.
Uh,
David Lee Roth is going to be on,
on,
yeah,
right.
David Lee Ross here on
Wednesday and on Friday,
Dr Amit Goswami,
a theoretical physicist.
So,
uh,
we have some crazy science.
We've got a rockstar and we've got one
of the funniest people on the planet and
we have Dr. Steven Greer.
Thank you very much for your time.
I really appreciate it.
Honored to talk to you and uh,
I really appreciate it all you're doing.
It's awesome stuff.
I love it.
I'm,
I'm fascinated and,
uh,
I can't wait to talk to you again in
April and I can't wait to see your film.
All right,
folks,
that's the dealio.
Yo,
um,
if you want information on the show
that Brian's got going on in San Diego,
go to death squad.
Dot TV is march what?
Brian,
14 14th at the American comedy company,
which is a amazing club,
uh,
in San Diego.
Really,
really cool place.
Uh,
thank you also to
onnit.com if you go to o,
n n I t use a codename Rogan,
you'll save 10% off any
and all supplements.
All right?
We Love Ya.
And we'll see you tomorrow
or Tuesday or whenever.
I don't know what to say.
I'm not telling you what to do.